If you guys don't know, your movie sucks. That's Adam. That's
Yms.
His media critiques are like really good. He's like got a lot
of thought going on. Yms is a furry. People just rediscover this
sometimes and he tends to make some arguments that don't paint
him in a favorable light. So recently,
a slop tuber named Rob's Media decided to take a swing at him.
Okay. Well, so people on Reddit are actually creating their own
form of propaganda to normalize and let you believe ostriches
are attracted to me cuz I raised it. These people need to be
stopped. And the thing is, if these people want to be humiliated,
I think they all enjoy my reactions to them >> Oh, so you're
just like, you're consenting to this. You're consenting to being
mocked for this? >> I assume so. >> With him, I think
there's a little bit of it. And I think a little bit of it >> is
someone in chat keeps saying, "Oh, Cherry's kink shaming for
free." For free today. >> Oh, yeah.
>> I think it was showed that it was a not safe forward
Twitter. Yeah, it was. But I'm saying uh Well, we we'll just
read Adam's message. Okay. Adam dropped this in response.
Uh, he also has I should go to the YMS page on YouTube because
I think I think
there's a community post there, too. I just want to make sure
I don't miss anything directly from him.
>> Can you guys hear me chew like this? >> Okay,
we got it. It seems to not be coming in. I could probably get
them to hear you by talking while you chew. >> No, don't
don't get them. >> Yeah, well, I'm not trying to, but I'm
saying that if I'm talking while you're chewing, it's probably
going to come through. Okay, let's uh let's read his his response.
Okay, he's typing up a Bible in response here. Kind of classic.
Little bit little bit classic. Oh, [__] This is not
working. Oh, I have to do it like this, too. Well, the timer
is going to cut off the top part of the text. There was a hit
piece video made about me that people are asking me to respond
to. Unfortunately, I'm out of town on the biggest work trip of
the year that I do annually and won't be able to provide a thorough
video response until I'm back in over a week. I believe this
was intentional. I've already left a lengthy and detailed comment
response with timestamps in the video's comment section.
Sorry, in the video's comment section debunking the claims. I've
reached out to the original video creator on multiple platforms
requesting them to pin my comments for visibility and transparency.
He has ignored me and refuses to do so. Even his friend who republished
the hitpiece on their own channel with minimal commentary has
refused to pin my comments responding to their claims. The reason
I'm not sharing a direct link to the video here is because it
contains detailed descriptions of images involving myself and
consenting adults. Oh no, this is him and the bulls. I fully
believe now that he got by two like fries in costumes and he's
got video he's got like pictures of that on his Twitter. I fully
believe that. I fully I fully believe that. >> Well, I'm
not going to fact check you. >> Uh well, Canadian caller,
you already took the sacrifice once and you're gay anyway. You
have to check it. Okay. You're the only man who's got the ability.
Okay. You've seen it. >> Are they gay or you just slandering?
>> Canadian caller Canadian callers gay.
>> I just I know that for a fact. They talk about being
gay or or they've convinced me they're by Oh, okay. Whatever.
Gayish. The reason I'm not sure >> by eraser. >> Yeah.
Sorry. He said, uh, so it's it's got pictures of him, uh, myself
and consenting adults, plus instructions on how to access them
with images and p of pages and usernames. Since my main account
is not set to 18 plus, I will not be sharing that here. The original
video, the original video creator, however, is perfectly comfortable
keeping these sections. Dude, there's something about reading
text that makes me want to yawn. I don't know what the it is.
If I'm watching a video, I don't have the problem, but when I'm
reading, I like Is that a thing? Is that like a
>> Is that a Like, am I dying or something? I yawn when
reading. Why >> is looking up? Why do I yawn? Why do I
yawn yawning indication? Actually Googled tired yawn. I'm not
border tired
>> This guy googled why am I yawning >> while I read?
He has ADHD. Yes, he is >> You yawning indicates Dude,
it's breaking my concentration. Dude, I like I just reading out
loud makes me want to >> Well, I'll read it. I'll read
it. >> Up. No, I don't want you to. I wanted to read it.
I like I want to beat the guy right now. Okay. >> Have
you tried
No, I have not tried Coke. >> I'm not even tired.
>> I can go get more caffeine, but Jesus, this happens
when I read articles and it's like I'm not even bored by the
article. I like reading and it's just like my brain up every
time. It's rude of my brain.
Okay. The original video creator, however, is perfectly comfortable
keeping these sections in his video uncensored to his audience
of YouTube drama commentary slob consumers, which we all know
have a higher than average percentage of 13 to 17year-old viewers.
Both him and his friend have the option to set their video to
18 plus on their end, but they refuse to do so, ensuring that
at least some minors are given detailed descriptions of explicit
material on how to access it. This is unacceptable and a clear
violation of YouTube's terms of service. Can I get the next comment,
please? Hello. Thank you. If you're an adult who wishes to view
the original video, make sure to sort the comments by new, then
scroll until you see mine. Then upvote my comment for visibility
so people can be informed that I have responded and intended
on responding more uh more thoroughly when I'm back in town.
For now, I'm going to continue to focus on my work during this
busy week. If you're upset that I'm not doing a video response
If you're upset that I'm not doing a video response until over
a week from now, you can blame the original uploader who either
planned plained this intentionally or didn't do any research
on me at all outside of copy pasting clips and JPEGs from gossip
forums. I know Kiwi Farms there explicitly. I'm not even tired.
If you aren't interested in watching this video, the TLDDR is
that it's more of the same I've already thoroughly responded
to a billion times on a billion different platforms. 10 to 15
years ago, I shared my perspective on various controversial moral
philosophical issues. And because I was in my early 20s, I didn't
phrase myself as well as I would have today. The 10th most viewed
video on the YMS Highlights channel is one of my responses to
this exact same thing happening years ago. Feel free to watch
that if you're
It is yet another absolute nothing burger supported by the fact
that these people always have to keep going back 10 to 15 years
for these clips instead of focusing on any of the lengthy and
numerous clarifications I've made since then. When my responses
like this one are mentioned, it's only ever framed as, "Wow,
he must be obsessed with the subject if he keeps talking about
it. >> Okay, stop." >> All the while failing to mention
that the only times I've ever mentioned these subjects is when
people demand I make a response to the same 10 to 15year-old
clips being dug up over and over. It is maliciously dishonest
and intentional.
>> Bro, you are like, it's contagious. Yans are contagious.
Why? Stop putting that on us. >> Okay, my bad. >> Oh,
yeah. Yeah. The framing of the original video is both ignorant
and irresponsible.
Making no effort to do their due diligence
for factchecking. No, I didn't yawn. I didn't yawn. I have Cheetos
on my tongue. Yeah, I swear to God, I just heard her yawning
from the other room. >> No, that wasn't a yawn. Okay. One
third of the video is pure speculation or outright fiction. Onethird
of the video is cherrypicked comments.
Um, I've over the years presented in ways that intentionally
remove nuance and intent. Onethird of the video is unironically
shaming me for being a queer furry.
I've archived their original post along with proof that their
videos are still accessible to minors without regarding any sign
in um without requiring any sign in to view them. They have both
been notified about how irresponsible this is. The original uploader
has ignored me and his friend wound up arguing with me in his
comment section attempting to justify their decision. It is apparently
not worth the ad revenue to prevent minors in their audience
from hearing descriptions of pornographic material with screenshots
showing how to access it. If anyone else can help me archive
information from these two channels before they delete them,
that would be greatly appreciated since I am very busy on my
work trip. Thank you.
So, wait, hold on. Is this is this from his Canadian caller?
Ricking the stallion on this teasing Tuesday. Fun fact, I had
another good boy on their knees servicing me from behind while
I filmed this. Who else wants to play with us? Location redacted.
Content warning. Teasing soft suiting. #teasing Tuesday.
Dude,
this guy is insanely den. But oh man. Okay. Well, so there's
all this. Okay. This I believe the friend must be Nicholas Dioro,
right?
>> Am I crazy? >> I must be. I'm pretty sure it's
Nick because Nick took some of his videos down and then he addressed
why he took some of his videos down today.
>> which like I think Nick wouldn't want to distribute
stuff like this. He might not have thought, "Oh, showing profiles
is bad." They might have some more friends. Well, it was um
Oh, man. It's like the transformational. It might not be. It
could be >> No, cuz on the 9th I don't think he talked
to Jurio,
right? I don't think they engage until like the 12th or something
maybe. >> Okay. Might not be Nick. It could be anybody
else. I just I kind of assumed it was Nick because I kind of
assumed that this is how he got how it got brought to his attention.
But Nick did eventually start picking this stuff up. >> Mhm.
Maybe we'll see in the next post. >> Oh, wait. No, no,
no. It wouldn't have been Nick cuz we there was a Nick video
where he watched the video and I think it's something from like
a day or two
>> Okay. All right. So, YMS keeps going cuz people start
responding to him, right?
>> Hold on. Absolutely crazy that these two idiots thought
sharing with minors was perfectly fine until getting called out
on Twitter. So, this is
I don't even know who the other idiot is.
Wait, what is this? That's just that. Okay. So, whoever the two
idiots were, called them out. All right. Call them out. Punch
zoomer. You mean when the you posted? Oh, these are the these
are the what do you call it? Rob's me. The your movie sucks video
was just taken down by YouTube due to nudity and content policy.
Despite this, the clip in question simply shows null reading
one of Adam's posts and that video is currently still up on YouTube.
The video was clearly reported by one of Adam's fans as only
hours earlier he made a tweet alleging my video violates the
community guidelines for a completely separate reason. He claims
that simply mentioning his NSFW material to a Twitter posted
to Twitter, a 13 plus website, by the way, is a violation even
though I never showed it in my video. Instead, showing YouTube
appropriate B-roll. If you want to watch the video, it's preserved
on it's archived on Preserve Tube. So I think so there was stuff
in there um but probably nothing horrible but he does he does
point directly to Adam's like not safe for work Twitter for sure
>> and it is Adam who is like hey these guys are doing
this bad thing. >> Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. So he I mean
it might have been people reporting from that. So Adam's going
to make the external linking thing. He's going to make the external
linking argument, right? Oh, hold on. This is uh there's this
one. So somebody somebody responds to him. This is sensitive
society. They got a pretty big YouTube channel. They got like
a couple hundred thou 500,000
>> So this guy says you're a [__] blaming/
accusing people for something so serious. I mean by that logic
you're a dog who likes a lolly and little kids and you're sharing
explicit content yourself. You've reviewed movies for children
and those same people are young who might are young who might
have followed your insane disgusting explicit account. Might
as well change your name to Yms445.
I thought I was pretty charitable towards you when we talked,
but it see but it see I was wrong. I'm going to expose you more
and tell my mom on you until you can't type anymore cuz your
wrists hurt so much from jacking it to the Lion King. You freak.
My mom was speaking. I don't even know where this turned into.
I don't think it was satire the whole time, but maybe it is.
Maybe it's just I don't know. In any case, okay. Uh well, I know
Hold on. I know it's an EDP 445 reference. Um, I think YMS's
point here is that he is very very strict about how he separates
his primary account, which is for everybody, and his like furry
stuff, that there are like some cross references, but they're
like scant and he does not directly link to any of his NSFW stuff
or any of his older content through his YouTube. That like his
YouTube is pretty disconnected from that stuff. I don't even
know if he backlinks from his not safe for work Twitter to his
regular Twitter. Like he tries to keep them separated. So he's
saying that like >> is it enough?
>> I don't know. I mean probably somebody could still find
it but it's at least like making an effort to follow the to.
He's probably saying that I I go like out of my way to follow
the to make sure none of my stuff's trackable to me. You making
that connection then putting it on YouTube is just as bad as
if I put that like if I put my only fans in my YouTube bio. That
would be really bad. Right. So you making that connection if
I can't do it why can you do it? You >> I think that's
where he's going with it. >> Yeah. Absolutely.
>> Greg Filman says, "I've followed Yms for years and just
now learned about the NSFW account." Yeah. So, it seems like
he the argument is that he's one of the most ethical degenerates.
Yeah, but that makes a difference. Okay. That does make a difference
that he's that he's trying to be ethical about it, that he's
trying not to like include any of that stuff. I think that makes
a difference.
I don't think it's nothing. I think like not paying any attention
to it would be bad. But Adam responds to this one says, "None
of my YouTube accounts lead to the myself." You did understand.
You You did that. Oh, yeah. None of the YouTube accounts lead
to myself. You did that. You did that on your YouTube channel.
How hard is that to understand? Why didn't you set the video
to 18 plus? Why didn't you blur the page/ usernames that you
were alerted uh when you were alerted of this? Why are you defending
>> So, this must be the friend. >> This is the friend
for sure. Yeah.
>> So, this seems to this makes like a ton of sense to
me. like, hey, it's literally like I'm not allowed to do this
because obviously tying, you know, my to my YouTube account as
as much as I could maybe make money from donations, that would
be really bad for like
YouTube. They don't want attached to this stuff. >> you
can't go and monetize linking my to my account. If I can't monetize
my own, then you can't monetize linking my to my account for
you. I think that's his >> I think that's his argument
here. And I think that actually holds water. I think that's a
reasonable argument.
So, we keep going. We keep going. There. There's all the fighting
between them.
And then
we've got this video that comes out
>> So, here's my situation.
>> This is the the YMS response. Okay.
The furry defense, the zoo file defense. So, we will >> So,
you recorded this 5 days ago. >> 5 days. >> So, that
says September 17th. >> 5 days ago. September 17th. The
next one I've got here, the next tweet I think is from the 18th.
Let's see here. I just want to make sure I don't have more tweets.
Yeah, it's the 18th.
>> Yeah, 18th, >> which is funny.
I'm sorry. If you look at the the tweet from the 18th,
can we pull that up?
>> I'll I'll go we'll pull up this one is first, I think.
So Nicholas Yorio
does uh >> this is just Rob's media's YouTube um Twitter
account and just showing that Rob blocked him. >> Well,
it's Rob blocked him, but also Nicholas got retweeted. Guy's
a total creep, by the way. He's desperately trying to slander
Rob's media YT as a child groomer to deflect away from his own
statements. Do I have this tweet here somewhere?
>> I don't think so. But this is like the start of a chain
where um >> Yeah. But also look at the look at the second
one that I showed you after this just because it's funny because
this is the 18th. Dioro is talking about him on the 18th after
Adam puts out his almost 2hour video defending himself.
>> So this is You want this one? Exchanges with Dioro.
>> Um I don't think this is the first the clip one. >> Oh
the clip one. Hold on. Let me find >> Is there not a clip
one? >> I've got like a lot of these. tweets here. Maybe
this is it. Nope. Oh, this one. This one. This one. This one.
Yeah, this one. >> Yes. And you would think, oh, he's pulling
a clip.
He must have watched the video and critic and this is like his
apt criticism from it. >> Yeah. Yeah. Hey, Yms. Why are
you giving your minor audience a tutorial on how to find rule
3? Seems kind of hypocritical. >> Make love, not war. Why
can't Why can't they use a professional movie budget for CG for
something that's actually worthwhile like Predator?
I should look some up right now. None of these are what I want.
That E621, that's a furry reference, right? >> I have no
idea. >> If I remember correctly, Rita's put that URL into
my Discord before. That E621, that's definitely like a Hold on.
E621.
That's a Yeah, that's definitely a furry like site.
Yeah, E61
is a furry themed boro style image board website primarily known
for hosting pornographic furry content. Yeah, I knew it. I knew
it. I remembered. I
>> So that's giving people instructions on how to find
furry.
>> See, they put aliens in there, too. There's one with
a demigorgon.
The top one has they have like weirdly human eyes. It's not bad
animation, though. Holy [__] One of these is 25 minutes
long. >> It's probably a distress signal coming from this
ship. >> What the hell? >> Yes, I'm searching up
Predator. That's how invested I am in the film. Make love. So,
this is his stream. But hold on. Let's see what uh let's see
what YMS says. This is the funniest response you could have given
because give could have given because you would know that this
was addressed in the video if you had watched it. Thanks. I think
that's just so funny the day after the video to and and now I
want to watch it cuz we haven't watched the that long ass video
that Adam put out.
But is it actually >> Yeah. I don't know. I don't know
if we're going to be able to will we be able to get through the
whole thing. That's a long video.
We'll speed it up a little The sinister version in my head is
thinking, "Ah, the best time to just make the worst arguments
is right after somebody puts out an effort post." Cuz there's
nothing worse than like writing out a 50page argument and then
somebody didn't pay attention to a single word of >> Too
long, didn't read. I'm going to call you an F slur for liking.
Like, >> why the [__] did you show people rule
>> Yeah.
Yeah. And
here, hold on. What? Nicholas responds here. Your response was
that you weren't shaming when showing it. Nice copout. And that
your editor included it as a fun gag. So why is there discussions
on looking up and browsing groggy
in your under 18 video? Is it only grooming when they are talking
about you getting in the app wearing a gorilla suit or something?
So I think Adam was like basically, oh, you shouldn't talk about
this stuff on uh on in your videos. Like you shouldn't talk about
where to find my [__]
I think if I
>> I don't know if he was making a groomer argument necessarily
>> now that I've like read his argument like now that I
read it out actually. I don't know if he was actually making
a groomer argument. I think he was saying
>> I think Adam was saying like it's bad but he was more
saying it's like a violation of to you would know it's a violation
of to cuz it's the same thing for like Only Fans girls to put
their Only Fans in their Twitch bio. >> It's a violation
for those people, right? You can't advertise your
Like let's say let's just use Twitch. On Twitch you cannot advertise
your O of on here. Me I can make content criticizing your create
your content on Twitch in association with you >> selling
luds on OF. I can talk about that to criticize you. You can't
link that monetarily. >> Can I link it? Is it okay for
me to link it or is the set up in such a way that like linking
to content. >> No, I can't I can't link to at all on >> I'm
saying even showing URLs for that be
>> because I think that's the argument he's making is by
showing my Twitter profile, you're basically >> Well, don't
say illegal against to
>> against us. >> Um, banable I guess. >> Yeah.
Anyway, >> I think they say for the purposes of
Obviously, you can't show. But if I if I am showing a document
and like, yeah, her name is the same name as on only fans, you'd
say I'm linking. >> I think I think the thing with YouTube
is the toos, including uh what do you call it? Like a policy
on YouTube where if you externally link to something that violates
to, you're also violating to. And I think you can do so by probably
he's maybe trying to make the argument that he's do they're doing
so by I think it would go back against him. >> But I think
he would just say we're both
>> probably if we if we go and read it or if we go and
watch it >> which I guess we're basically there where we
can go and watch it now. >> So he's got his he's got a
massive response here.
It's huge. It's huge. Hour and 37 minutes. It is broken into
sections. Holy [__] Intro/resent context. Moral philosophy
discussions. Animal welfare. Animal welfare. Consent. Summary
of thoughts on animal welfare. Lol. E. Scarjo. Thought experiment.
Start to hit peace discussion. Start to hit piece discussion.
Coincidence. Lack of research. SL surface surface level farming.
Fur shaming. Nicode shaming. Uh content warning children
start of Adam's response discussion. Hit piece directing to Adam's
ad account. Uh adult account response to Adam's comments. Shad
man addressing Adam's community. Mental struggles sh fur shaming
continued. Hit pieces backloaded. Adam's need to explain himself
and his thoughts thoroughly. Commentary community hive mind.
Response to Adam's comment continued. Eclustorio continued. Inappropriate
sharing of content continued. Kira the wolf. Adam's moral perspectives.
Public safety concern.
Outro.
>> Oh, also wait, it's not about external links. It's the
It's the viewing age.
So, actually, I I would agree with Adam for that reason. All
they had to do was make the video 18 plus. They're even talking
about content. >> Where he's going into detail about that.
How hard is it to just make your video 18 plus? >> Uh,
really hard. You know how how the advertising works for 18 plus
videos. >> Who the [__] cares?
>> That's the whole thing. They're just trying to sneak
it in under like some AI filter to get the advertising going.
You know, that's like all they're trying to >> that's it.
That's it. That's all. Guys, we've got an hour and 22 minutes
left on the stream right now. We are nine subs away from another
hour on the stream. If you want the content to continue, if you
want to keep if you want it to keep going, if you want us to
be able to finish Adam's entire response, although I don't know
if we'll do the entire thing, we might skip through some sections.
You want us to do the whole thing though, you got to donate.
Donate. Donate. Okay. You can sub on kick. You can sub on Twitch.
You can give subs on kick. You can give subs on Twitch. You can
buy a TTS message. Exclamation point. Donut. Donate in the chat.
Exclamation. Exclamation point. Donut. Exclamation. Exclamation
point. Donate in the chat to get the links. Okay, there's the
Kickbot link.
There's Kickbot. There's Streamlabs. Bye. TTS message. Sub. Give
some subs. All right. Add some more time to the stream. Appreciate
you guys. Going to continue on with the content right now.
>> So, here's my situation. Yeah, I guess I'll explain
for people who didn't know.
while I was at TIFF, within the first 24 hours of me showing
up at TIFF, >> that's the Toronto International Film Festival.
TIFF. >> Did you go back to the long hair?
>> You don't like the short Oh my god, the nails. Oh my
goodness.
>> Oh my god.
>> Oh, no problem, BC. Thank you.
Within the first 24 hours of me showing up at TIFF,
a hit piece video gets released
about me and essentially the entire thing is just like
>> Let's go. >> Yo, Private Huff with the five gifted.
Let's go. Four subs away from another hour on the stream. Thank
you very much, Private Huff. Let's go. Let's go. Let's >> For
10 more subs, I'll chew into the >> Don't give those subs.
Wait, do give those subs. I I like money more than I like being
entertaining. Go, go, go. Kiwi Farms, right? Like somebody read
my Kiwi Farms thread.
Zero skepticism.
Accept it at all as fact.
Meanwhile, they have like,
you know, top 10 Sam Hyde moments on their channel and their
Instagram is a picture posing with him. And it's like, okay,
well, if you're going to take Kiwi Farms just at face value,
then like, you know, don't they have a thread accusing him of
being a Isn't there like a bunch of [__] about that?
Anyway, dude, >> I this is like already just so bad. This
is like already >> exact
Sam Hyde.
>> at face value as a picture posing with him and Sam Hyde.
Meanwhile, they have like,
you know, >> let's talk about the guy who's making the
content, I guess. top 10 Sam Hyde moments on their channel and
their Instagram as a picture posing with him. And it's like,
okay, well, if you're going to take Kiwi Farms just at face value,
then like, you know, don't they have a thread accusing him of
being a like, isn't there,
dude? I It's It's just so disingenuous every time. I wish you
hadn't started with this cuz it's like, if you want to make your
response, I'm I'm here watching your response, but why are you
just going if you want to take Kiwi Farms at face value, just
say they lied about something. But they they didn't really lie.
I don't think this video mischaracterizes his um like I I wasn't
really listening to be honest the commentary to YouTuber. I was
mostly laughing at how bad he was at making his own argument.
Like the times where he talked I was like laughing at him for
being a >> right. Like I just watched the clips. I can
see your clips. I don't think like our our commentary so far
has been pretty on the like just watching you and the words >> and
you're right. I am kink shaming you. But I'm not. That doesn't
scare me.
>> I'm going to keep kink shaming you. And so your defense
is
Sam Hyde is a >> Yeah, Sam Hyde. Guys, if you're just going
to take Kiwi Farms at face value, why don't you read the Sam
Hyde Kiwi Farms thread is apparently his response.
>> I don't know how that helps. They're like a bunch of
[__] about that. Like anyway,
so that's already kind of weird.
so they released this video of me while I'm at Tiff. I don't
even know about it until like 3 days into it. And the only reason
I find out about it is because I'm getting messages on my phone
being like, "You're Europe posted to my Facebook."
I'm like, "What?"
>> Okay, that's rough. >> Who's on Facebook? >> That's
pretty rough. >> I'm noticing some extremely dedicated
trolls go find this guy's Facebook to tell him he's a >> like,
you know, other comment
Very unhinged, very like
Like legit it seemed like minors just the way that you know the
way Excuse me.
>> what you good buddy? What is he eating? What is this
>> way that they were talking?
generally the type of people to
been grooming his scar. Okay. You know go on a weird tirade and
accuse
you know, show up to someone's page and start a thing like that.
Generally, those people tend to be minors. And so I'm like, okay,
what's going on? And so I ask,
you know, my editors, like, is there something that's going around?
Cuz I don't even know what this is. They're like, okay, yeah,
this video has been going around. I look at it. It's got like
at least 50,000 views by this point. the the YMS greatest hits
>> and it's from a channel that has like almost 100K subs.
And so, you know,
videos like this have been made for my entire time on the internet,
you know, not starting out, but as soon as I was like big enough
for it to be a thing. Um,
but this one was getting a good amount of traction as in,
you know, it was I knew about it because of the comments that
I was getting.
Yeah, I think we can we can speed him up a little bit as well.
Um, Ken the Jelly Man says, "Where are you at on the pity ridicule
spectrum with YMS currently?" I think this guy specifically is
somebody who keeps this like to himself most of the time. I'm
not like super against YMS. I do think it's like super DJ. I
don't think his arguments are the best, but like he at least
knows like not to try to keep this in like the main part of his
content. And I think this is like a healthy reminder that don't
keep this in the main part of your content. And I hate that he
I don't like that he feels like super stressed out or super like
up from this. Like I don't want that. But it it's like it is
weird and I do think you publish way too much of your [__]
to expect to not be made fun of. Like I'm sorry you can't have
these other random like accounts and then not expect not to get
made fun of. I'm I'm sorry. That's just that's them's the breaks,
bro. So you're giving him the autism handicap. No, I'm not giving
him the autism handicap. I don't know. Listen, he said he doesn't
have a dog. Okay,
if he had a dog, there'd maybe be some concerns or something,
but
he ain't got a dog, man. Anyway, um people were saying that I
should,
you know, answer for I guess my thought crimes, which my thought
crimes are not even the accusations. They're not even like, okay,
I'll just explain from the beginning. So, I'm the type of person
where I I have always valued the concept of free speech and open
expression, right? My core audience knows this. uh my core audience
knows that I'm a person that like finds a lot of value in philosophy,
right? In a lot of uh moral, ethical, philosophical discussions
and that I'm the type of person that promotes the idea that like
in most cases it's not like black and white, you know, there's
nuance to most things. There's gray areas to most things, right?
And so if somebody has a position of like, oh no, 100%
this, then I'm the type of person to go like, well, you know,
there might be a scenario. It's
Okay, guys. I'm just I'm a devil's advocate, okay? I'm a contrarian.
Sometimes when somebody's like, "Oh, it's 100% this." I'm like,
"Well, what's 100% really,
right? That it's not 100%. Here's an example of something fitting
into the 1% or whatever, right?" And so
various
various subjects have been requested for me to give my positions
on uh in Twitch chat or whatever, you know, like live streaming,
playing games. Uh these subjects include abortion, right? Assisted,
drug legalization. >> I Oh, that was uh include No, no,
no. Yeah. Yeah. But the clip was definitely from the Lion King,
the live action version, right? assist
>> legalization the live action >> you know like
many countless controversial topics that me as an early 20s something
year old
>> I'll I'll just point out that on most of those controversial
topics people will go okay like even though we disagree we both
understand that there's like some weight to both sides there's
not really there's just I'm sorry you don't have like a 5050
it's not 4951
on should we or should we not [__] the dogs, >> right?
Like abortion, even if you're vehemently pro-life or vehemently
>> you can go, well, I understand why this is like a conversation
we have to have like because it's extremely consequential. It's
extremely important. It's extremely like life-changing stuff.
And it's like, >> that is not the conversation around dogs.
If you don't [__] dogs, your life is like 99.999999%
the same. >> We say dogs. I he just says like consensual
non-harmful animal fornication or so. I don't know what the [__]
you would call it, but yeah, it's just like
Yeah, there's just there's there's nothing.
It's not something >> and it's never a conversation of
why I need to. It's always a conversation of why can't I >> Yeah.
Give me a >> give me a good reason I can't >> give
me an ethic. Give me a way I'm harming humans, another person.
Okay. bying this dog. What this dog and I do, what what consent
what consenting adults or animals do in their own bedroom. I
don't know. Something along these lines.
>> When my audience, you know, the amount of people watching
my my Twitch stream was like 30 concurrent viewers, which, you
know, not that different from today, I guess. Um, yeah. I mean,
will I get distracted if TTS is on? Whatever. It's crazy that
I I guess I I do understand streaming to like not that many people
probably, but like like 20 or 30 concurrent. I can't imagine
doing that as a guy with like a million YouTube subs where you
like make videos and like people will like like tons and tons
of people would it like it feels so weird to me that like you
wouldn't um or that you'd get like a lot out of streaming to
like 30 people when you have like such a big platform somewhere
else. It's not that it's rough, it's that it's like I just don't
it feels like a weird use of time. >> But I've always I've
always done streaming like since I started streaming basically.
There was like a period of like three months where it was like
just fun and then it started making enough where I was like oh
if I do this as a job it would be like good. So like I didn't
have a long period of time where I just did streaming as like
a hobby which a lot of people get. So I don't know maybe that's
like different from most people.
>> I don't know. It's just like it's kind of weird to me
but I I don't know. Yeah. He just likes the community feel. Yeah,
that's fair. I like uh I do like when when things slow down a
little bit, we do like community stuff like Spooky Sunday and
then it's just like Yeah, it's more comfy. I don't know. It's
like a different feel. Maybe I get it from that perspective
a little bit. I'll keep going. Many controversial subjects and
people would feel comfortable asking me about these subjects,
right? And I was comfortable
just speaking my mind. So, one of these controversial subjects
is animal welfare. Oh, hold on. Uh, I was thinking I might join
the Discord. Yeah.
So, I'm going to go join that. You'll have to hop in. Wait, hold
on. You should do that. Hold on. I'm just going to go for her
in a second.
One second, guys. No worries. I just going to go join for you.
Beep. Okay.
Give it a second. Give it a second. Give it a second.
Hello. Hello. Hello. Yo, what's going to happen? Oh, this is
going to get weird if we can hear each other, but it's >> Wait,
what do you mean? We can't hear each other. >> Oh, right.
Oh, I Hold on. Do I have this? I'll have to see if I have it
set up correctly. >> You do?
>> Wait, but can you hear your voice through my thing?
>> No, it's the same thing as doing a call.
>> No, it's not. It's not. We're both going through my
mic, but it's fine. Or specifically like human animal interactions,
right? And my position has always been that even though I would
like it not to happen, even though I don't like that thing, you
know, I have no interest in it and I would prefer if other people
don't do it, if you give me a world, you know, where no people
are doing that versus a world where people are doing that, I
would choose the world where no people are doing that. Right?
That's always been my position. However, I do find it stupid.
I don't think that's true. I don't think
so. you
for him. I don't think most people will entertain a purely hypothetical
like
uh what would you call it like um thought experiment
to the point it's like significantly detrimental to their career.
I just don't think most people are are interested in that. >> Yeah.
No. And I think there's some amount of like there's something
additional there that's going on. Whether he knows somebody who's
done this or whether like it's kind of sort of like an overlap
with the furry thing. I don't know. And I don't like I Yeah.
I just don't get it. >> Like I would say the casual normal
person who ever talks about this is like buzzed, drunk, bored
at a party or at a >> Yeah. Yeah. It's like conversation
that they wouldn't even have sober. >> Yeah.
It's just it's Yeah, it's odd. It's just odd that he's like that
invested that he was doing it. And this is like already he's
like cate categorically like different already in his response
where it's like I don't like the other times he's not like explicitly
saying no, no, no, I don't want this. I don't want this world.
He's like not very careful about that at all. He's like going
way hard in the other direction. But we'll we'll keep listening.
We'll see what else he says. that many of our legal policies
regarding this issue are not based on the welfare of the animal,
right? And so if you look at
the things that we consider to be acceptable, ignoring the meat
industry, right? So literally just animal breeders and you can
do that for fun, right? You don't have to be a licensed animal
breeder. You can just be someone that's like, I would like to
play God. I would like to combine these two animals into another
one, right? That's legal, socially acceptable. In order to do
that, like they interact with the animal, right? Um,
this is not a debatable fact like that. This is this is real
life. It's happening right now. Um, there are podcasts of like
doctors talking about the different ways they do it. Uh, they
opt to do it usually by the animal because it is less harmful
for the animal than letting them do it themselves. Like this
is true, right? This is this is verified scientific, not debatable,
right? Um,
and so that same action, right? If somebody if somebody is doing
it but has a different thought in their head, right? If their
thought isn't, oh, I'm going to take this semen and force another
animal to be pregnant because I think it's funny or whatever
and I just would like to play God. If that's not their thought,
but their thought is instead, oh, this is hot or whatever,
people believe that person should be in jail, which if you believe
that, that's fine, right? But just admit that you you want them
to be in jail for a thought crime, right? You want them to be
in jail because of what was happening in their brain, not because
of the welfare of the animal, right? if it was because of the
welfare of the animal, then you would also believe that other
people should be in jail for doing the same thing. Again, not
even considering the meat industry, not even considering that.
So,
you know, so that's that's been my argument. And then the second
argument with animal welfare is um
so this is the um this is the thing where he's saying, okay,
I wasn't I wasn't listening to be clear. I was I was trying to
do something otherwise. >> He basically said he's I guess
making us straw, man. Everyone's problem is they want you to
go to jail. >> No, no, no, no, no. It's it's that um basically
like all of these acts are totally fine. You allow all of these
acts. You allow animals to be penetrated for like uh like force
breeding or stud farming, right? Or be jerked off or whatever.
The you allow all of these acts, but the fact that somebody would
get off to it is what makes it bad. As in, you don't want to
penalize animals being abused. You want to penalize somebody
getting off on animals being sexually abused or simply pleasured
in some way. that like you're willing to accept those things
happening,
>> but you're not willing to uh >> but you're not
willing to let me have it happened for me like when I'm getting
off on it. And so this is like we said there there are things
that are like conflicts where I don't actually know if you would
like with somebody who's not getting off to it and they're if
they're engaged in stud farming, they're dropping this horse
off for some reason. They're not getting off on it, then I believe
that they would put the horse's well-being first. I don't know
that you have the horse's well-being in mind when you're doing
it, right? Like there is a conflict there suddenly where it's
like a mechanical this has to be done thing and we're doing it
for the sake of like some other purpose. And with you, I don't
know if you'll like actually prioritize the the animal being
like like out of pain or whatever the [__] I don't
know what you you'll do there, >> Yeah. And then what do
I have to do? Review the tapes of you doing it because you are
going to come back and tell me no, he loved it. Don't worry.
It's uh >> I can't take your word for it if I know that
you above all else are getting enjoyment from it, right? >> You're
not like a reliable narrator when you get something from being
allowed >> you can't be trusted. Yeah, you can't be >> And
I'm not going to review the video to determine whether or not
the horse is enjoying it. >> I That's where I lose you.
>> No, you're not losing me. I'm like about to say guys,
if you're being a weirdo in the chat, you're not going to be
here very long, okay? So, have you just consider not being super
weird in the chat? Thanks. >> Just thank you. >> Jesus
Christ. >> More of a philosophical one. >> No, just
the just the people being odd. >> People will ask you have
to be sexual degenerates in the chat. We're literally making
fun of degeneracy. Read the room. Read the room. We're shaming
people like this. And then you guys are like, "Oh, I I do this.
I do this thing." >> Weird weird people. Okay. People saying
weird [__] I have this kink where I just like to
be respected. I like to I like the person I'm with to have like
respect for me and probably respect for people of my gender and
my race. It's what I'm into. >> And now I'm starting to
see why >> why why we're breaking. Okay. All right. Play
the video. >> People have asked me, "How is it possible
for an animal to consent to a human being?" Right.
And my answer was
>> Sorry, that just as like a pause that just works. So
>> how is it possible for an animal to consent to a human
being? Right?
And my answer was, >> I will just be your pain. >> My
answer was, well, >> Ruben donated $3.
>> People, please shave your comments. >> Seriously,
thank you. The same way it consents to another animal. Now, people
have interpreted that as me saying animals want to have sex with
human beings and therefore it's all good or whatever. People
have interpreted that as me saying all actions,
you know, towards animals are permissible because of that. No
>> animals. What's he talking about? He's and he's not
even he's not even doing a good job. It's like we're not saying
we're not saying you're saying you could animals in whatever
way you want. We're saying that you think there are permissible
interactions between human and animal humans and animals which
you obviously do. >> That is not my position. My position
is that sure it's possible, right? So when someone presents me
with a >> Yeah. And we we also don't like Vosch going,
it's actually possible for an adult and a child to have a like
>> a sexual relationship and it benefit both the adult
and the child. Like, yeah, that's not that's not a good argument
either, Bosch. No, not >> Bosch. No, Milo. >> It's
like, oh yeah, it's possible. Okay, I don't I don't care. This
is 1,000% not possible. And I go, okay, well, it's probably possible
based on I don't know, look on any Reddit thread about dolphins,
right? One of the most upvoted comments will be dolphins people.
I don't know. Like that's not informed consent, but they're clearly
doing a thing, right? They're they're initiating a interaction,
right, with a human being. Otherwise, we wouldn't be saying dolphins
people. We would say, you know, the human dolphin, right? If
you look up like I don't know anything about
>> Aren't dolphins just prehensile? So, they're basically
like a big claw, big like thing they can grab [__]
with. >> I've never seen a dolphin's
>> Am I crazy? >> But why do you say it like that?
Aren't dolphins like never saw or a lot of you out here having
seen >> they said aren't they prehensile?
>> Yeah. Are a lot of you out here just informed on dolphin
>> dolphin prehensile >> like a claw. This said I
didn't I didn't say like.
>> I didn't say like
you had a very you were very >> prehensile. Yes. Dolphins
have prehensile, meaning are capable of grasping or manipulating
objects. >> As in they can grab things with their
>> What the They have like a hand at the end of their >> No,
it's like a It's like a tentacle.
Like you can like wrap around and grab
>> That is horrifying. >> But that's like why I don't
even know if they like as much or if it's just that they're as
useful for grabbing things with. They don't have like hands.
They don't have thumbs. So maybe they're that's the only way
to grab people. So they're like not trying to they're just like
using their whip to Indiana Jones things over to themselves.
>> I like already had a mental image of what it meant to
get ripped by a dolphin and it just got worse. >> Yeah.
Well, not good. I'm just saying people people know what I'm saying.
People get it. Farmers and the relationship that they have with
ostriches, right? Like they're species of animals. >> Wait,
what? Ostriches >> saving people. We would say, you know,
the humans a dolphin, right? If you look up like I don't know
anything about ostrich farmers and the relationship that they
have with ostriches, right? Like there are species of animals
where they literally won't reproduce unless the human being is
around. And that might be a result of domestication obviously,
right? In the wild that doesn't happen with ost
What do ostrich farm? Wait, why did Xanderhal want to go to an
ostrich farm? >> No, no, he did. No, he didn't want ostrich
farm. He wanted um
>> Quails. Yes, quails. >> Sorry, it was quail. You're
right. You're right. It was quails. which is appears to be something
where like they see the human as like the alpha or something
like there's a bunch of different examples right so I've said
uh things like
you know
things that are part of our common knowledge in pop culture like
America's funniest home videos right there'll be a clip of like
a woman fell down a hill and then the dog just starts humping
her and so my response is is the dog not consenting to some sort
of act by doing a act on the human right sure it's not informed
consent right and that doesn't mean oh dog's hunting you therefore
you can do something else to it I never said at right. I'm saying
that the act in of itself that the animal is doing is one that
it is consenting to. Right? By their version of consent, not
by my version of consent, which is informed consent. So my standard
for the people that I have with is informed consent. >> I
don't like I don't like to be a link spammer. Yes, you do. >> My
goodness. >> What do you mean you don't like to be a link
spammer? >> Okay.
What the >> It's a king of the hill thing. Hold on. You
go first. >> I did some AI reporting. >> Okay. for
AI researching. Now, I'm reporting on the AI of ostrich farmers.
They do tend to they want to be involved with the chicks, the
ostrich chicks at a young age so that they're familiar with them
so that they can be um more influential or they they deal with
each other better um when they're older, right? They'll let them
around, let them handle the eggs and stuff like that when they
grow up. And it's shown that ostriches raised by humans may develop
attractions to their caretakers which can lead to difficulties
with natural breeding according to Reddit.
>> Oh well. >> So people on Reddit are actually creating
their own form of propaganda to normalize and let you believe
ostriches are attracted to me cuz I raised it. These people need
to be stopped. >> Turns out it's all why I'm >> There's
a reason. There's a reason why YMS was on Reddit last year. He
is creating the the that's going to feed the AI algorithm to
let you know it's okay to this dog. >> He's doing his own
reporting. He's doing his own manipulation of the of the info.
>> Arguments. Let's go. >> Hank molested my dog.
>> Boy, I tell you what, this is one
just a second, Duke. Hey, this is where I got >> Hey, cut
it out. What's going on? >> There's nothing wrong, but
maybe you should get out of the pool immediately.
What do I do? Have fun. Get the manager out here.
>> All right. Thank you for the clip. Thank you. Hank will
buy a dolphin. Classic. Love Mike Judge. Might have to watch
Office Space again soon. We'll see. What did Mike Judge did?
Silicon Valley, too, didn't he?
>> Oh, I liked Silicon Valley, but I don't think I got
past like the first season. Yeah, there's an update to King of
the Hill, too. I watched some of that. It >> Oh, yeah.
>> Was okay. >> Yeah, it was like okay. It was like
okay as in I watched a lot of it when I was a kid, so it was
like cool to see it and see some new episodes, but it was like
okay. Wasn't Cotton Hill's gone. >> What the hell? >> Cotton
Hill's gone. And you know, he he really tied the show together.
>> It's unfortunate. >> Consent. Not just informed
consent. Actually, enthusiastic consent, right? Like I'm a
liter
just because I have a belief that yeah, it's probably possible
based on not informed consent, not informed consent, but whatever
version of consent that animals have, which I would assume they
have to be able to have, unless we're to say that every animal
having sex with other animals is like two two animals having
sex with each other. That's not right. Like maybe if we we'll
say that it's if it's like ducks or whatever, but like we're
not saying >> two people if two people with
profound
have sex with each other. Is that like 50 IQ?
I'm like I'm one of those people who doesn't think about people
with 50 IQ having sex. >> I just I don't know. It's all
about like diminished capacity for for this. I think there's
just something to be there's something to be said for like you
are the person with the
the additional capacity
and that like probably there's something there that you should
appreciate the subtleties and and how something can consent to
you that shares your like intellectual
>> I'm of the belief that I'm watching somebody with 50
IQ have consent takes right now because why the is he doing this
on camera? >> I don't Yeah, I don't know, man. A goofy
guy. He's just a goofy guy. Okay. Okay. >> Nope. Don't
don't read it. >> Don't don't read it. All right. I won't
read it. >> That every instance of every animal having
sex with each other is has that position. Correct. Therefore,
they have some version their own version of consent, right? That
they are capable of. So again, it's not informed consent, right?
It's not the human standard of consent. I was only ever talking
about the perspective of the animal which people who get really
emotional about this
just forget it or don't have the ability to wrap their heads
around. Right? So yeah, that's all my positions on animal welfare
is
the laws are contradictory. Doesn't mean I want it to happen.
It doesn't mean it should happen. Right? Just they appear to
be based out of disgust for what's happening in someone's brain
rather than actual concern for the animal. And I would like it
if people were honest with themselves, right? And then consent
like sure it's possible right it's not informed consent it's
not >> okay if that if that were his only point okay is
that it's it forms from disgust in the I would just go yeah probably
there like some things we socially punish that we can't necessarily
defend the whole like as much as like everything else that we
could you know sort of rationally
defend and there is some amount of discuss factor there but like
I think it's probably a society healthy discuss factor it's like
something that's just require not required Like it's it's literally
the same as the thing where it's like I understand how you're
making the argument like the gay twins. I understand how you're
making the argument. Like I I get it, but I I'm just fine with
it like not being something we ever go like, "Okay, you can do
that. It doesn't hurt anybody."
>> I think my brain is going to be permanently stuck on
we all have a disgust factor and you've just randomly
"Oh, this turns me on."
>> like you went you didn't just normal normalize it. You
didn't shift a couple inches towards the center. You went all
the way to the other side of that.
>> And now you you can't get off on anything but lions
apparently now. >> Specifically types of drawn lions.
>> I don't want to hear about societal whatever morality
arguments. Shut up. Explain why you're over there. I'm sorry.
I'm a king shamer now. >> You want to if you want to participate
in society, you got to be kind of like society. I think there's
something I think we've gotten way too much in the like we're
going to celebrate everybody who's a little different. It's like
no, we should
>> I don't need to celebrate you. >> Turns out bullying
people was actually a good idea. Like keeping some sort of societal
consensus was decent. >> I don't need to celebrate you.
I just need you to come out with a tell all book like Lauren
Southern. Explain what happened to you when you were a kid. Explain
what happened during the Lion King that made Cigar like >> Scar's
personality attracted to you. So which one of your uncles does
he remind you of? Like >> explain something something to
map this on to me. >> Yeah, I would love not my standard
for consent, but it seems possible, right? It seems like they
have their own version. That's I I don't see why that's such
a big deal for me to have said that. Anyway, third thing, I guess
second thing that there were two parts to the animal one, but
third thing that's now now floating around as of I guess the
past year. Something that I haven't talked about for over a decade
and I honestly forgot I even like said this
because the clips so old like over 10 years. I don't even know
how long it was. It was like no it has to have been like 10 years
ago.
Anyway, my position somebody asked me what I think of like the
ethics of lolli whether or not it should be illegal, right? Right?
And I said, "Yeah, lolli should be legal." What I should have
said is at least decriminalize, right? I don't know. Like I was
in my early 20s, but I essentially have the same position where
if there are only consenting adults involved in an action, even
if that action is someone drew something that is disgusting,
that I think is disgusting, that most of us think are disgusting
and offensive. Right?
If the action only involves consenting adults, I don't think
people should go to jail for it. Right? That doesn't mean I think
it should be celebrated. That doesn't mean I would like more
of that to exist, right? That doesn't mean I would like it to
be out in public and available like on a grocery store shelf.
That just means I as a principled person, right, with strong
feelings about like harm reduction when you put people in
wait,
stop, stop, stop. One to has the answer. Pat Cherry Sai, I've
heard YMS talk about it and it comes down to one, Jeremy Iron's
performance, and two, he can fix him. >> Okay. harm reduction.
When you put people in jail for the rest of their lives that
that's causing harm, right? If someone is doing something that
only involves other consenting adults, they should not go to
jail. Now, if you come up with a scenario and you go, "Well,
what about this?" And your example involves someone else who
is not a consenting adult, then obviously that's not what I'm
talking about, right? As soon as you as soon as you come up with
a scenario that involves someone else who is not a consenting
adult, then they should go to jail or face some sort of consequences.
Like, I don't know. like it's clearly not a black and white issue,
right? You know, if if if some people are saying they don't believe
that there's a single person on the planet that's attracted to
like anime characters that isn't also like attracted to children
or whatever. I don't know if
>> he's making the Destiny argument for why people should
watch. I don't think Destiny that's not his argument. >> I
don't I don't think that's >> that was the argument. If
if research will conclude that they are less likely, then he
would be supportive of that type of treatment, but it would require
there to be like consens consensus.
>> Yeah. Consensus and something like that. >> It
would have to be proven that it does
>> Yeah. Yeah. >> The primary principle being whatever
reduces harm to kids is the thing you need to do.
>> If I believe that, right? Like I don't I don't believe
that everybody that wants to Twilight Sparkle wants to [__]
a real horse, right? I want a Scar from the Lion King. I don't
want a real lion. So it's really easy for me, you know, to imagine
what it would be like to be another person who's not me and be
like, "Oh, okay. There's probably people out there, right, who
might be attracted to like
I don't know, Doky Doi Literature Club. Is that No, that's not
what was I even talking about. Lucky Star. Just think I don't
know. some anime where it's like I don't even know if
I don't even know. I don't think I've watched an episode of Lucky
Star, but I do remember the opening. >> How can we
horrible, horrible, horrible,
>> how can we be sure that Tylenol didn't also cause furries?
We can't. Time. Only time will tell. >> That's true. Just
Just get rid of Tylenol. Okay. Nobody needs Tylenol. >> I'm
positive after Charlie Kirk's assassination though that the furry
community will be studied a lot closer. >> Uh yeah, the
the FBI will get to the bottom of it. Okay. Cash Patel is going
to be watching a lot of furries from now
>> if he wasn't already.
Have I told you about the thing that happened with the gang and
of the goat? >> No, you've never mentioned the gang and
in India by Indians. >> Okay. You've never mentioned that
before. You want to tell me more? >> It was like nine of
them. I believe that gang rap and they they gang they didn't
afterwards. The gang killed the goat
>> and luckily they >> like the gang killed the goat.
>> They the goat to death the goat to death. Yes.
>> Sweatpants freedom just got it. Um sorry not that but
yes tragic with the goat. the Trump built. >> I'm waiting
for the Trump pill pain pill to replace Tylenol.
>> Sweatpants freedom. I don't know if you watched earlier,
but I was like, "Oh, when I was watching the press conference,
I'm like I'm just waiting for them to tell me how whatever their
autism curing pill is actually owned by like Trump people." And
then it was like Dr. Oz owns a company that sells that exact
pill just every time.
Every time with these people, it really depends on the person's
mind, right? And so, you know, guaranteed there are people out
there who are attracted to Twilight Sparkle and real horses.
Guaranteed those people exist. Does that mean everyone attracted
to Twilight Sparkle is attracted to real horses? No. Right? Like
there's there's vendagrams you can make and there's people outside.
There's people that fit in the middle, right? Like not everyone's
the same. So I have to just as a thinking person that doesn't
want people to have their lives ruined for consenting activities
between adults, I have to extend that logic to other people other
than just myself. I have to be like, "Okay, well I know that
I don't want to a real lion cuz they're stupid and unhygienic,
right?" Like there are qualities about real >> that's the
only >> There had to be dude. So come on, man. There was
another quality. There was at least one other quality you should
have thought of there. I >> They might eat you.
They have no They don't have human level intelligence. They're
incapable of consent. There's like a whole bunch of things that
should have come up there that just didn't. >> First of
all, aren't they click >> Aren't lions very smart?
>> No, I don't think so. >> Are they not the king
of the jungle? >> I think they call them Wait, no. Aren't
tigers the king of the jungle? >> Are tigers? Lions don't
live in the jungle. Where >> Where do lions live? >> I
think they call lions king of the jungle, though.
But lions don't live in the jungle. They live in like the savannah.
>> Like like grass lions. >> They literally don't
even live in the >> plains. Plains, you say? I don't know.
>> Um but did he just say that they're
>> So one shower to a lion will change half of this argument.
You're 50% more attracted to real lions as soon as you bathe
one. >> I guess so. Yeah. What did he say were his reasons?
>> Cuz they're [__] stupid and unhygienic,
right? They're stupid and unhygienic. Oh, true. He did say stupid.
Diminish consent capacity. Sure. Yeah. Yeah.
>> There are qualities about real lions
that I find so unattractive that I cannot get about like there
are qualities inherent to real life animals that are so unattractive
that the only reason I can get off to cartoon half animal halfhumans
is because those features don't exist there. Right? So, it's
so weird because I brought I I made this argument in the the
comment section for that video. I tried to come up with like
a thought experiment because, you know, I'm I'm the type of person
where it's like, okay, I'm already a furry. It's not that difficult
to understand that because I know that myself, right? Like, I
don't I know how that works in my own brain when it comes to
lions, right? I'm attracted to scar for the combination of human
and animal features. I am not attracted to a real lion. So, it's
very easy for my brain to understand how this works, right? But
I understand that you know like normies people who
you know get to get off to let's say Scarlett Johansson right
let's say Scarlett Johansson is what you got off to my thought
experiment >> I oh hold on let's see what is okay if you're
attracted to Scarlett Johansson or whatever you're attracted
to like think about this in your head right be honest with yourself
be super critical like genuinely give this a shot are you still
attracted to Scarlett Johansson if you remove features of intelligence
hygiene right communication
Oh, hold on. >> there's a lot of the internet that would
be more attracted to her if she stopped bathing for a month.
>> Uh, yeah, but regard Okay, regardless of that, if he
was dumber, I'm sure. But, um, this guy >> her value just
went through the roof. >> This guy This guy has never heard
of Max. Okay. Max loves when they barely They're brain dead,
actually. Like, that's his favorite thing. So, >> they're
in a coma. >> All of the pressure of goes out the >> Yeah.
There you go. Um, he doesn't need 3 days to prepare anymore.
It's he uh So, also I just want to point out that he does the
the lolly arguments are the same ones he does for for this stuff.
And it's like, okay, you understand that like those aren't the
same trade-offs you make with the lolly stuff. In fact, there
are very few of those trade-offs in some cases. Like, yeah, you
get some diminished intelligence, but it's like there none of
the other trade-offs you described are like there because it's
a human, right? like he's describing the trade-offs of going
to an animal instead of like a anthropomorphized like fantasy
thing, but that's not the case with uh with Loi. It's like like
you are going to a human, but it's like that they line up way
more than thing like you have a disconnect. You have something
that doesn't really exist. >> I also I feel like this is
just a sign of I have never real people before because I don't
know if you know this, but when you have sex with someone, there's
no pop quiz in the middle. No one actually knows how smart I
am. >> Yeah. when there's like a dick in your
>> Nobody knows.
>> Verifiable evidence that this guy is. Okay. On his not
safe for work Twitter for his account. Okay. Verifiable. >> He's
being dishonest by saying that what makes him attracted to somebody
is how smart they are. >> How smart they are. That's true.
He probably does not ask a lot of questions of people before
he those costumes.
>> But he doesn't. >> So she she can't communicate
with you. She literally has the brain of a child or animal, right?
Walking around with a helmet.
She's herself doesn't know how to like shower. Are you still
attracted to that person? The correct answer is no, right? And
if that's the case, if you are not attracted to that person,
then you should understand what it's like to be someone who is
attracted to a fictional halfway point that doesn't exist in
real life. All you have to do is swap, you know, the Scarlett
Johansson in real life with the fake Scarlett Johansson that's
like baby brain. Hi, thank you so much, Crow. Right? Like it's
a thought experiment that I was hoping
people would be able to look at and be like, "Oh, you're right.
If you do remove those features, it makes it unattractive." There
might be like, I don't know, a certain a small percentage of
guys where they're like, "Yeah, I would still bang." And then
they might think everybody else thinks that way. Like I that
might just be them telling on themselves, right? If people seriously
>> wait, why is it them telling on themselves in that situ
like attraction is not a combination of features together where
some features existing can make you unattracted and some features
existing can make you more attracted. Like if people don't believe
that and they just go base only silhouette species is the extent
of attraction. If they believe that they're telling themselves
what they're admitting is they would Scarlett Johansson with
a child brain, right? Like that's that's what they're admitting
if they believe the world works that way, right? Um, anyway,
so those are my positions. >> Yeah, I just
those people are telling on >> Someone made a video where
they took all of the clips from Kiwi Farms and, you know, Reddit
post or whatever. They >> dude, at least he can identify
the slop. Okay, this guy read my Kiwi Farms thread once and just
took the clips and he made a video. 100,000 view video, by the
way, for no reason. Just repost my Kiwi Farms thread one to one.
>> Piled them together. And it would be one thing if it
was just like, oh, here's all the he said. Here's all the [__]
he said on this subject. Shame him for his opinions, you know,
like he thinks this. Like that's what all my all the people accusing
me. It always starts with he thinks, right? Not he's done cuz
I haven't done anything, right? This is all just about like thought
policing. And my thought crime is not even not even like, oh,
lollies or blah blah blah blah. Like I'm not into that, right?
My thought crime. >> You're doing well despite it all.
>> Oh, thank you, Mr. B Natural. My thought crime is believing
that other people shouldn't be imprisoned and have their lives
ruined for thought crimes. That's my thought, right? Anyway,
um, thank you, inverted arrow. This person creates this video.
It's released within 24 hours of me arriving at TIFF. I made
a lengthy comment on their video. I also DM'd them. They've ignored
me everywhere. I DM' them on Instagram. I DM'd them on Twitter.
And they're posting, right? They're posting on these accounts.
They're checking other DMC
people trying to understand the nuance of society's expectations.
Autistic Oh, what? >> Oh, sorry. Go ahead. Go ahead. B
autistic people trying to
people explaining the nuance of every detail that might or might
not make someone you wouldn't drooling Scarlett Johansson, right?
Yeah. >> That's like he I don't think he realizes like
if he understood or if he was like socialized well I think he
would know that I have to make it really clear that I don't want
this all the time. All the time. I have to always make this clear
that I don't want to [__] with animals. I don't want
to [__] with animals. I don't think we should have
a world where you're allowed to [__] animals even.
I just think if somebody did it, I don't really think they should
go to jail if there's they could prove. But it's like it's still
like you have to drive home the other part so much there. Like
you have to do it in a like at a equal clip to how off-put people
are by you just thinking it's okay to have sex with animals in
any like situation. >> And I've reserved the right to just
like laugh and mock you for how terrible of a disaval you do
when you say, "Yeah, I don't I'm not animals. I don't want [__]
animals cuz they're so dirty.
I'm you you are telling me you want to >> Animals are just
they just stink. Okay, they stink.
Come on, man.
Like, yeah, it's hot. Okay, that hot that lion in the pen is
hot. But like, imagine what it smells like. >> Okay, stop.
Stop. >> stop describing how much you don't want to the
animal. Okay, Jesus Christ.
>> Like, at least give a convincing one. Like, no. No,
no, no. I went flying because he would probably
uh claw past like my skin. He would wound me, might kill me.
I'd be afraid for my life. No, he's over here worried about the
hygiene of the lion.
What the >> That is what that is his number one concern.
That lion stinks. That lion >> They're responding to other
creators and other drama people. They're in the comment section
of other drama people streams completely ignoring me, right?
I can only assume
just for the purpose of like being able to dehumanize me, right?
Cuz it's easier to create this type of content if you don't actually
have like any personal interaction with a person, you know? Anyway,
so the fact that the fact that there was like no way
I think YMS could convince you he's not a horrible person.
>> I think if he was in a call with you, he'd be like,
"No, no, no, no. I think he could convince you. I think he could
convince you that like >> Oh, I'm sure. I feel like half
of these people, what they say on their streams or what they
say like in a video,
I get concerned that they just want to rage.
>> They want to rage bait. They want to be
>> And the thing is, if these people want to be humiliated,
I think they all enjoy my reactions to them then. >> Oh,
so you're just like, you're consenting to this? You're consenting
to being mocked for this? >> I assume so. >> With
him, I think there's a little bit of it. And I think a little
bit of it, I don't know. We'll see. We'll see what his reaction
is. How much he
I don't know. I I'll never follow it
>> is someone in chat keeps saying, "Oh, Cherries kink
shaming for free." For free today. >> Oh, yeah.
>> Like some people would pay to be ridiculed online. >> Yeah,
I'm sure. With this guy, I think um we'll see what he does with
that not safe for work account if that like embarrasses him out
of it. If it doesn't, it's like I think you kind of
>> you're probably cool with it as long as it's not done
in like huge doses that over your channel. You're probably like,
"Yeah, give me a little bit of that." >> But I feel like
they were doing that with this one. And I think he pointed it
out like, "Okay, this I got to this big event and within 24 hours
this is
>> Right. This is meant to go viral and for people who
see him in person at this event to
maybe talk about it or something. I don't think a lot of people
who would go to that event would know him. >> You would
hope so. But this but this event was taking what what is on
>> um different accounts and linking it to your movies
suck.
>> Your movie sucks. >> Your movie sucks. Whatever.
>> So, it looked like the goal, maybe it didn't have the
effect, but the goal seemed to have this little humiliation ritual
reach him in real life. >> Son is bad. I think he was saying
more that it was so he couldn't respond
>> for it to reach him in real life.
>> I think that's more what he was thinking, but it could
be either one. I think it's probably so he couldn't respond right
away though. >> Or I don't know. He also might just have
been paranoid there to be honest. I don't know if the slop tubers
would have done that much research. They tend not to. They tend
not to know like when is this guy going to TIFF festivals? Yeah.
What the [__] is TIFF?
T FF the Toronto International Film Festival in Toronto, Canada.
One of the most respected and uh and cultured events, film events
in the world. Thank >> To even
get any kind of acknowledgement from them >> irritated
me. Uh the fact that it was posted within 24 hours of me going
to TIFF, which is 11 years in a row, the biggest and only like
work trip that I do consistently every single year. I've pointed
this out in their comment
And the response from their audience and the response from other
people in the commentary community like Nicholas Dioro who streamed
about this last night. Their response is basically what do you
expect that they would know your entire work schedule? You must
have main character syndrome. >> Wait, that's worse.
That's why would you alert them? Hey, I'm at this IRL event.
Can you not do this right now? Now I think he's
>> I assume based on his conversation with Sensitive Society
that one of the two of them or both of them reached out for
>> Yeah. Cuz like he said, "Well, I told you about this
or something." Like they would have talked.
>> Oh, no, no, no, no, no, no. Sorry, I'm >> It was
the opposite. >> It's the opposite because he was there
and he started getting notifications. >> Yeah. On his Facebook
people calling then he had to hear he had to message his editor
to find out, is something going on? >> Yeah. Yep. >> Yeah.
And then these people, he tried messaging them. They didn't get
back to him. And the only time that someone got back to him was
the not Rob's media, but the friend started arguing with him
in the YouTube comments. That's the only types of responses he
was getting.
>> Yeah. Yeah. Okay. Get these nails.
>> I'm not expecting any random person to know. I'm expecting
someone who made a mini documentary about me to know. Right.
That would be like if I did an edit, by the way, edited. This
is this isn't a live stream video we're talking about. This is
an edited produced video, right? where they compiled things together,
added their own commentary, decided what to keep, decided what
not to keep, order YMS figuring out that some of these YouTube
commentary people are not good at research and they don't. They're
just lazy who do the easiest like bottom of the barrel [__]
Oh my god, it's like hitting them. Oh my, it's almost like they
didn't work very hard on this. It's almost like they just kind
of threw things together and >> h it's almost like they
they kind of suck at this. Yeah. No [__] >> They
created a narrative. They made a little mini propaganda documentary
video. If I was making that about anybody, I would know. That
would be like if I was making a video about Daddy Derek and I
released it right when he was at the 420 awards, right? So me
saying that I believe that's malicious, that's the more charitable
interpretation cuz the less charitable interpretation is that
he just like didn't do any research, which genuinely might be
the case, right? So it's either maliciously intentional or maliciously
ignorant because there's no there's no person, right, that'd
be creating a little mini documentary about somebody pretending
to have done research that wouldn't know about this, right? It
was on my subreddit, right? It was in my videos. It was on my
streams. Any of the most recent things I was doing is like literally
I live streamed me going through my TIFF schedule, create going
through all the movies I was going to watch, right? The guy says
he used to watch my channel. There's literally one thing I've
done consistently every year other than I guess the Oscar stream.
>> Right. But the one thing that involves me being out
of town. So yeah, it's either maliciously intentional or maliciously
ignorant. My big issue with the video when it came out was not
just the fact that like oh conveniently this is at the beginning
of my like two weeks away trip where I'm not at my computer and
I can't like >> respond on screen
>> it's it's that plus sorry I lost my train of thought
this is really annoying it is really annoying >> have you
ever seen the Patrick nail >> it's that along with the
fact
>> my goodness >> this is him right now >> did
no you did no research He did no research. He takes Kiwi Farms
at face value.
It's literally just factually incorrect information because he
made
a post on Kiwi Farms. The reason why I know that he's literally
just copying and pasting from the thread is because they're the
exact same, the exact same
comments that I made, right? They're found there. It's not just
I would I would expect from the standard of quality that like
I try to put out to the world for things >> Yeah. That's
not the It's not the same standard of quality. This guy I think
works this guy's perfectly at home swimming with the film people
who do like the every frame of painting.
Like he he will break something down. He will take like 30 minutes
of content and turn that into a 10-hour thing, right? Like he
he probably takes like movies, breaks them down into like 12
hours of like his
>> and then slowly edits away the things he thinks are
like the least essential until he's got like an hourong product
that he can put out. Right. Mhm. >> These guys are like
like 10 hours of research, five hours of writing, five hours
of editing. Let's go. Right. He's like he's watching the movie
like a 100 times to like or at like he Yeah. It's I think it's
like way different. Way way way different,
bro. You'd be making 10our segments out of one video. Yeah. And
And it's the best. This is the best way to do it. that are edited
videos, especially things like serious where you know like the
ramifications are people in your audience are gonna, you know,
go on their Facebook page and call them people are going to try
and cancel this person. Like you you should you should understand
that there's a seriousness associated with the content you produce,
right?
You should look up primary sources. You shouldn't just take it
face value and copy and paste from one.
Now, here's the thing is I think he's going to say basically
that like I had further Reddit comments that made this clearer
in like the same threads. And I would agree with him that you
could go look for the same threads, but also things could be
deleted. And it's like I don't mind grabbing the thread from
like the archive from KF.
He should have probably looked and if there are more comments
there, I'd say that's probably a little bit bad. If it cuts against
your narrative, if it was like if it's more stuff that's along
the same lines and and doesn't really cut against the narrative,
then maybe you could leave it cut. But like you should probably
go look and see if there's something that like breaks your narrative
that's probably incumbent on you if you're going to publish something,
right? I'm trying to think of like what he could have even said
because I don't think listening to his clips I don't think I
misunderstand his positions at all. But I do like but he seems
to think that this guy really badly misrepresented him. And outside
of a couple places I don't think that's necessarily the case.
Drama thread, right? That's irresponsible. That is irresponsible
content making. So I know that not everybody in the content,
you know, commentary community is like this. I know that like
regardless of what you think of Turkey Tom, like the dude actually
tries to like make sure that there's a level of quality that
is met for his videos, he has, you know, multiple different people
working on them and editing and, you know, different writers
and he's not like micromanaging everything. Um, but there, you
know, like he he takes it seriously and he understands like he
understands that there's like a level of seriousness that should
be taken with that, right? Regardless of what you think of his
political beliefs, regardless of what you think of like how charitably
he is towards some groups and not others or whatever, there is
a standard equality there. There is not with this guy that made
this video. That's what pissed me off. And now
is is responding on his stream, which I've archived by the way,
so don't pretend you didn't say the [__] where he's
saying like, "Oh,
the call out." Oh my. Oh, hold on. Hold on. I I need the sound.
I need the sound. Oh man. Where do I put that one? Need the need.
Oh,
okay. We needed that. Rob's not >> I feel like um Nick
is one of those people who probably assumes that his gets archived.
He just takes it down if he feels like it's going to hurt him
on YouTube, right? >> He takes he takes everything down
because his live streams will get demonetized and then spam report
>> Well, no. I think it's just purely monetization. Okay.
>> He just doesn't want his live streams taking away from
his videos. He he'll just edit them down so they could be remonetized.
So basically when you stream live you can be green monetization
and then after it finishes it'll review and it'll go oh I have
to knock you down to yellow and then he takes those down and
then edits them so that he >> so nothing ever gets knocked
down to >> So nothing's ever in yellow. He could always
make the money off of all of it. Yeah. I'm not a journalist.
Like things things that like ethically I was saying should have
been done to prevent the spreading of misinformation. Nicholas
is just like oh we're not journalists. Who cares? And like that
that's their that's their opinion is just like it doesn't matter
like that there's no seriousness taken about this. There's no
standard to try and meet like >> uh oh I'm being I'm being
slowly pulled back onto Adam's side. You just keep on commentary
YouTubers and I'm like wait
what's one red rocket amongst commentary haters? Okay. >> I
don't agree with that. I don't agree with that. Like am I Kim
video? Could you imagine if I just like copy and pasted from
like forums of what other people were saying and didn't like
look things up myself, right? Like no, that would that would
be a bad video. That's bad. That's a joke. That's just a joke.
That's a joke. I
Right. Um and so within this video, the reason why I call it
propaganda is because it's not just, oh, here's the things that
he said. It's here's the things that he said packaged with a
huge chunk like literally maybe a third of the video saying here's
other people that aren't him that have said similar things that
have had controversies where they've done something predatory
and he says in the video oh you should connect the dots you should
connect the dots over a third of the video I'm pretty sure over
a third is literally oh this is probably the actually the best
this is probably the best
um counterargument in Adam's favor is yeah >> connecting
the dots with Vosch is connecting the dots to his abusive like
him actually engaging in behavior, messaging people who are minors
or who are very young or impaired in some way have diminished
consent capacity in some
>> Connecting the dots, you can connect it to some abusive
thing they've done. Destiny, connect the dots to some abusive
thing he's done. >> YMS connect the dots to
him letting two black bulls him on Twitter. It's like, well,
he hasn't. That's actually two adults him like is there is like
actually not a thing where he has abused a person
>> who are connecting the dots on. Sorry. >> Oh,
I'm sorry. You think I'm naive. You think that I wasn't just
promised that these other people had no skeletons in their closet
>> and that that was a defense that they never did. Drake
was too famous. Drake's too famous to be accused of half the
>> That I that is Yeah. >> Nah. [__]
that. >> I'll connect the dots when find your dot. Little
little rough. Little rough. Yeah. Now that's a that's actually
I'm just saying the name of his victim. >> Yeah. Yeah.
Oh, Little Rough. Is that a black joke? >> It's a dog joke.
>> Oh, okay. >> You're just shaming me for being
afraid.
>> A lot of rappers start with little. >> Okay. Is
it a dog joke? >> And then, you know, they got like there's
a a group called Rough Riders. Never mind. Okay. >> Dog
joke. Over a third of the video, I'm pretty sure over a third
is literally just shaming me for being a furry. Right. There's
section there's a section timestamped in his video called furry
degeneracy. There's a section stamped in his video literally
just about me liking Scar from the liking. Yes. Romantically,
yes. It's a fictional character. Combination of human and animal
features. He uh takes streams where I've talked about being attracted
to his face, his voice, his smile, his personality, his body
language. and his editorializing of those comments is him saying
that I claimed that I'm not attracted to animal features at all.
Oh, look, he just thinks it's a coincidence. He's trying to claim
it's a coincidence that it's a lion. No, there's a combination
of human animal features. I've never said anything else, right?
I've never said I'm not attracted to any of the animal features
on this human >> I think Wait, wait, wait, wait, wait,
wait, wait, wait. I don't think that's true. I think the ar the
argument I perceived to be happening was the slop tuber was saying
I don't think it's clear that you're not a zoo file because you
seem to be attracted to Scar who is not really anthropomorphized
at all like there is some there's some amount with the face the
eyes and stuff where they're anthropomorphized where they're
made to be more humanlike but realistically like you like Scar
and you've gotten commissioned of like you Scar or something
or Scar you when it's like just the lion not the not the >> can
he stop saying he's attracted to his
Scar murdered multiple people. He abused his nephew.
He He sent his nephew out into the wilderness to eat bugs. >> Try
to get Well, I mean, trying to kill >> Try and kill him.
He took over the pride and let them starve and die for the hyenas.
He's a traitor.
>> What the is attractive about that? >> His voice,
it's baritone. He his personality apparently. What kind of personality
is that?
>> What are you supposed to do?
>> I love this song.
>> I know that your powers of retention
are as wet as a warthog's backside.
But thick as you are, pay attention.
>> Okay, stop. People have to join the
>> to watch this after stream. >> Oh, you want to
watch Lion King after >> Yeah, we're going to watch after
stream. >> Okay. All right.
Okay. We're back to Ys here. We're on to fur shaming. We're first
shaming >> normal character. >> Oh, guys, we are
three three two
three subs away. Three subs away from another hour on the stream.
>> Let's go. >> Three subs away from another hour
on the stream. We can finish off the whole video. If not, we'll
go somewhere in the middle and probably end it up or end it.
>> I am not attracted to animal features on an animal.
In the same way that hopefully hopefully you wouldn't look at
Scarlett Johansson's if she's attached to like a mental patient,
right, and think, "Oh, that's hot." Like, hopefully you wouldn't
think that. Otherwise, you're dude, nobody can see Scarlet. Nobody
can see Scar's. What? This guy can't even pretend to be a little
bit straight. This guy can't even pretend. Like, nobody's seen
her.
What are you? That's not what people are attracted to about her.
He's like, I assume with women, people like the vagina, right?
That's what you're attracted, the vagina, right? It's like, brother,
what are you what are you doing? That's >> go with the
one everybody sees. Go with the cleavage. >> I was telling
like this is this is how human brains work. These are I don't
consider them to be complicated conversations, but I keep having
to remind myself that to many people they are because you know
Nick, I'm sorry, but like you you in your stream going over this
like there's there's some like genuine comprehension issues like
when I was talking about like that that analogy for human animal
features and trying to relate it to someone who's not a furry
or whatever. He his his takeaway was that's the same excuse that
people would use to children. And then he plays a clip of someone
saying something along the lines of like, >> "Oh, it's
fine to [__] a child or to a child as long as it's
for different reasons other than it being a child." That's not
the analogy, right? That's not what I'm saying. I didn't >> wait.
Turn what? >> Turnit has a point. I feel like we can't
watch Lion King after this. We have to wait like a week. >> Oh,
it's going to be ruined. >> Maybe we wait a little bit.
Yeah, sure. >> We'll figure out something else to do in
>> there might be YMS fans watching this with us right
now. Yeah. And someone before him said gooning together to lion
kings and it >> kind of kind of rough >> like that
that analogy for human animal >> and trying to relate it
to someone who's not a furry or whatever. >> He his his
takeaway was that's the same excuse that people would use to
children and then he plays a clip of someone saying something
along the lines of like oh it's fine to a child or to a child
as long as it's for different reasons other than it being a child.
That's not the analogy, right? That's not what I'm saying. I
didn't say it's fine to [__] a lion if you think
that the lion has human features, but it doesn't, right? That's
not a real lion. We're talking about fiction, right? It only
exist. What I'm attracted to only exists with the human features,
right? There's no other version of that that exists.
That's what it is. That's the package, right? I'm kind of I'm
kind of disappointed
because the, you know, like I'm I'm like friends enough with
some of the people in this uh like drama YouTube commentary community
and, you know, I've followed a bunch of them on Twitter and they
follow me back. There's like a mutual thing there with like a
good amount of them. Um >> I you know what I Wait, actually
I don't >> You don't know what >> did YMS I think
YMS might have did he make a comment on my thing when I got >> I
might I might actually just be totally full defense of him if
he if I go back to my um >> when I got YouTube banned.
If if he went back if he gave a comment if he replied or if he
quote tweeted that I uh
I'm going to full on defend this guy. I got to go find it. Um
Okay. >> He's done it with I'm mostly joking. He's uh I
probably have the same opinion, but I think he might have. He's
definitely done that with a lot of people. He He seems like a
guy who's like at least communitywise, he's like nice to people.
He's not He doesn't seem like a super hateful guy. >> Listen,
I have trust issues. >> Yeah, that's fine. You're telling
me somebody with
degenerate proclivities
tries to appease and help a lot of people in hopes that they
support him when he comes under fire?
>> Okay. Before >> private hop, thank you for the
gifted
>> guys. Two subs away from another hour on the street.
>> Two subs. >> See, let me see if I can find it
here. Would he have done that? Wait, that's not it. Oh, hold
on. This >> like what? I'm trying to find my my comment
to YouTube. >> Um um >> and I was hoping for like
a little bit of charitability, but essentially what has happened
is because I responded in that comment and also yeah, first I
responded in the comment. I pointed out Oh yeah, this was the
thing that I almost lost my train of thought for. This was my
other really big issue. I pointed out that in the video this
guy insisted
on sharing
a page with username on blurred, right? Showing exactly where
to go of images of myself and consenting adults, right? And it's
not just saying, "Hey, this exists, right? It's not even just
saying the name of the website where this exists." It was describing
images of me and describing the race of the person I was having
sex with. As if it's relevant for it to be a black guy. I don't
know why these people think that that's like,
if you're curious about what >> it was him having sex with
the black bulls. Okay. It totally was. I called it. I knew it.
>> I saw it. Okay. I saw the video. his channel is like
that's a good >> not in a literal sense. >> Yeah,
I guess. Yeah. No, it's not basically king shaming. It's absolutely
king shaming because >> no that's a kink guy. >> I
pointed this out in the comment section being like, "Hey, this
is against YouTube toos. Also, why is this video not set to 18
plus? If you're not going to set it to 18 plus, just blur the
username. Just blur the username." Why is it important for you
to have the video set to all ages where minor could access it
and you know at least some are because you make [__]
YouTube drama videos. Come on. Hello. Like that's a way lower
age demographic than talking about New York and Jalon films,
right? like you know that you have minor in your
blur if it's important for you to say oh let's
not hid it and like not being afraid of that being accessible
to adults like yeah I have accounts
that allow adult content that allow adult content and adult accounts
and I pointed out in the comment section the settings that I
have enabled on these websites ensure that if there are minor
on the website Right.
They don't have the ability to access it. And I tested this yesterday.
By the way, >> I Why is he doing this, though? I don't
believe that you're allowed to have YouTube videos discuss any
form of kink and not be set to 18 plus. He doesn't even have
to make a deal about the
>> It's talking about furries. >> It is talking about
furries.
>> Bam.
Already a violation.
>> Yeah. Although I think you are allowed to have like
some amount furries might not be listen >> for 18 plus.
>> No, no, no, no, no. Listen, after Tyler Robinson, he's
changed the whole landscape. Okay, people have to be able to
talk about fries now.
>> Tested this. I created a fake account with like a 13-year-old
uh birthday or whatever just to test this out because I'm I take
this very seriously, right? >> Oh, we had Will from TX
with the new individual sub. I think that puts us one sub away
from another hour on the stream, guys. Will from TX, thank you
very much for the individual sub. >> I I created an account
on this website just to test it out. You cannot see any of the
media displayed on my page, right? And in a search, it doesn't
autofill,
right? If you try the username, which I'm not going to share
here because I like I make a conscious effort to keep that stuff
separate from my work stuff and from stuff that's not age gated,
right? There YouTube doesn't allow on it. I have accounts on
websites that do allow
what's the big deal? But they're trying to act as though this
is like a moral uh issue that needs to be brought to Yeah. I
I think you can literally make fun of So I think you could totally
go like push you could totally like knock down all the arguments
about king shaming. I could talk about you and the weird you
put online. Okay. >> I do think he might Mackenzie Carter
Cameron, thank you for the gifted sub. I think he might have
a point on like did you really have to put the names in there?
Did you have to do that? Do you have to like tie the actual like
couldn't you just say what's there? Is there really like a public
interest in you putting my name and tying it to me tangibly on
YouTube in a way that I can't even do for myself?
I don't think there's an argument there for doing that
actually. Yeah, I don't think so. >> I didn't know that
that account existed.
I didn't know this much about him. So, I do feel like for him,
this is um
I think he personally just would rather they not make that link
publicly.
>> Yeah. But I'm saying like I understand why he feels
like like it's actually wrong to do like like mixing those two
>> Okay, stop. Because he's doing it from a school boy
I know the rules type.
>> But he I think he specifically feels like he benefits
that he can't do that.
>> He might.
He's also like that. But that pulls away from like the kink thing.
Like he likes being humiliated because >> Well, I don't
know that he likes being humiliated. I think you're trying to
convince me that. >> No, I Well, I don't have to convince
you of that. I'm saying that like >> 100% he likes being
humiliated. >> No, no, no. I'm saying that like
either he likes being humiliated and he wants them attached or
he doesn't. But then I don't know why he's even complaining about
this if he like wants them >> That's true >> is all.
Now, I don't want to say negative things about him unless he
gives me money
>> to everyone's attention. Not only say that it exists,
but ensure ensure that traffic is directed to my account and
describing the images, describing
explicit material to guaranteed minor in their audience. And
Nicholas Dioro's response to this was showing a clip a clip of
one of my videos in my Prey
where I'm watching the movie, the webcam's on me. I say, "I'm
so bored. I'm gonna look at Predator." I don't describe any of
it. It's not on screen, right? And then one of my editors,
>> I feel like you describe it a little bit. You don't
describe in graphic detail. You describe it a little bit. I in
the video, you describes it a little who made this edited version
of the video. Decided, okay, we're going to make this into a
little joke. They put the words E621, which is not a specific
page that leads to these images, right? This is >> a You're
now giga turbo
hyper coping. What the
This is I put I put in my like thing that's not really sending
people to there's like an age gate there >> like uh no
>> okay buddy >> no just a vague this is like saying
oh right I don't even know. >> Okay so okay you could say
that if I say exists people know exists. If I say E621
people don't necessarily know. Okay it's even a little more.
I use the example, so he kind of owned me there. But >> E621,
no, you can kind of you like that that sort of begs to be Googled
in a way that doesn't
everyone knows E621.
Yeah. Yeah. But I I don't necessarily think it's like the like
he did something evil there. I just think it's probably a little
inconsistent >> putting the DJ [__] that he
shouldn't have in there. >> I Yeah. Yeah. I think it's
pretty DJ. Know if the images there were like from E621 could
have been on I don't know. Rule 30. >> E621 is a furry
image board. Furry image
>> like you're allowed to say rule 34 in the video, right?
I didn't describe any of the these images beyond saying, "Oh,
a demigorgans's in one. Haha, that's funny." I didn't >> no
Accelerate E621 is not just MSG. It is also a >> Say what
acts are taking place in the images. I didn't say who was penetrating
who. I didn't say which race was popping, right? Like I didn't
say what hole was was being inserted by what thing. And also
it's not in the context of let's shame this person, right? It's
not in that context. It's in the context of haha, this may be
so boring that I'm going to look up and then like some images
were displayed. I'm sorry that that's not a good argument. And
I think Nicholas, this is a part of one of their arguments specifically.
Which one was it? One of the arguments they had explicitly. It's
uh
find it. I can't find it. [__] Yes, it's the one.
Yeah, right here. Your response was that you weren't shaming
when it show was showing up. nice copout and that your editor
included it as a fun gag and it's like I don't know like they're
going to argue that they need to shame you that like the shaming
here is like a social shaming that's required. I don't know if
like sh using it to shame means you
maybe you'd argue that if you're trying to stand on a soap box
and and shame this guy then you should be like above reproach.
Maybe
I don't know. I don't know. Let's continue. On screen that I
made sure, you know, I made sure that the the editor sent me
that everything was censored to such a degree where you couldn't
even tell if it was, you know, it's not like two characters on
top of each other and then sensor bar where like their hips are.
No, these like the only images shown were censored to the point
where it's just like, oh, you can see the face of a predator
and you can see the face of a demigorgon or whatever, right?
They're not even like in the same spot. And then the editor also
put in like I don't know. I guess there was like a longer story
video on the like I don't I don't even know if it was the same
image as I looked at because the editor just did their own thing,
right? Um but they showed a clip as a part of a joke part of
a joke where
excuse me
these nails are new. >> Dude, this guy's got to get used
to >> Excuse me. >> They showed a clip as a part
of a joke that may or may not have been from like a but there
was no in the clip, right? And so, yeah, I don't I don't think
that the same amount of factors have been met
when I'm referencing that a website exists, right? Just saying,
"Haha, funny." And then there's some images that are so censored
that I don't even know if they're like legit. Like, I don't even
know because they're censored to the degree where like you can't
tell. And that's the point, right? Where like we there's no I
don't even Yeah, there was no sex in the images anyway. It was
just like the the context of that image would have been, "Oh,
they're just posing." There weren't even Yeah, there weren't
even any sex in the images that were heavily censored. me. You
didn't know that until you were just told. It seems like >> he's
like he's like realizing, oh, somebody whoever edited it is giving
me better arguments in on the fly, right? >> Um, but yeah,
I mean like doing that for the context of a joke where I'm not,
by the way, the guy literally said, "Go to this website if you
want to see these images." He described he described these images
in detail and said, "Go to this website if you want to see them."
That's so many steps beyond what I did. Right? If you want to
call me a hypocrite,
Right? There's nothing about what I did that's malicious. The
reason why I believe what he did is malicious is because when
confronted about this in comments that yes, he read when confronted
about this, he didn't do anything about it. He knows that he
was creating content where there are guaranteed minors in his
audience that are being described in detail. Like literally saying
what's going into what hole and with what race. Like that's what's
in his video, right? Uh describing the content, showing the page,
username uncensored,
saying this is what the page looks like. This is what the the
profile picture looks like.
This is the username and here's where you go to find these images.
If he wanted to create uh I do think that guy probably
I'm surprised he's getting around the YouTube to cuz I do think
YouTube when you do graphic stuff that's I've seen a couple people
get clapped for that, right? Graphics content. I think
>> Chud got grabbed on the Vosch DMs. Cleman got hit on
the Destiny Rose DMs,
>> right? Like reading out content like they don't like
that. They don't >> think you're doing graphics descriptions
at all. >> So,
he might have a point that is against the content guidelines,
>> the exact same video.
>> And if if if his argument is, I don't want to censor
this because it's something people need to know about, right?
If it's that important for him to let more people know, miners
included, that I have accounts on websites that allow adult accounts
and adult content. If it's that important, why not just censor
the username? Because of course people can find it for the fuckingelves
if they try, right? Like the conversation about like miners finding
on the internet is not oh we can make it so that zero miners
find on the internet. No, you have to try. You have to put in
a good effort. You have to make it so that like you're taking
reasonable steps if only just for your own liability. Like even
if you don't care about whether or not miners are saying like
just for your own liability, right? This my comment existed for
2 days. Both him and his friend that reuploaded the same video
with minimal commentary but kept the exact same footage. I alerted
them in their comment section. I didn't go anywhere else about
it. They did nothing. They did nothing about it. and his friend
argued about it to me as if this was something worth defending.
Literally, not just, hey, he has an adult account somewhere,
but here's the username, here's detailed descriptions of what's
on it, and go access it if you would like to see it. Right? Those
are so many steps above anything I've ever done. Right? And again,
this is in the context of not, haha, it's funny that this exists.
This is in the context of we are shaming him for being weird.
We are shaming him for being a furry. We're shaming him for being
queer. And the the the entire video is propaganda because it's
packaging the completely harmless
queer furry [__] that I do with consenting adults
incredibly ethically, incredibly responsibly because
this is a white half furry. Okay, white half furries in in this
in this doing the most ethical, most conscientious
furry suit you can imagine. Okay,
is I've enabled all of the settings that prevent miners from
accessing it on those websites. I have I have ensured that none
of my safe for work accounts lead back to that. Right? That is
incredibly ethically. And he goes, "Oh, no. I don't actually
care. Everybody go to this website. Everybody go to this exact
page." Right? I'm not going to pretend like, "Oh, it's revenge.
You took images that like were private." No, they're public images.
Public to adults, right? Any minor can create an account and
just lie about their age depending on what country they're in.
And I guess there's some places that need ID. Why do you want
to increase the amount of minors doing that by showing them this
on a website that doesn't allow adult content? That doesn't allow
adult content and on your video that is set to all ages. Right?
That's insane. I don't know why you're defending that. I don't
know why your friend is defending that. I don't know why Nicholas
Diorio is defending that. That is that is clearly clearly a line
that is crossed that I don't understand how that's not against.
I think it is against to maybe we can like pull up the you know
document, right? Maybe I don't know. Is there someone from YouTube
that like can inform us on whether or not this is against? And
so Nick's response about this to me is that me saying that it's
against to
is me inherently calling for people to strike down and remove
the video, right?
Which if you read my comment, I said it's against to
adults go to the video and upvote my comment. I said to upvote
my comment because he refused to pin it. The guy who made the
video refused to pin my comment for transparency. And yes, in
that comment I say this is grooming behavior and I call him out
in all caps and you know I do a little skitso, right? I was mad
because I was typing this as I was at Tiff in between excuse
me running around watching four movies a day, right? Like yeah
when you are so irresponsible that you publish something that
demands my attention that you know is demanding my attention
that you you're creating because you know that people are going
to ask for me to answer for this right for my thought crimes.
When you're creating that content and you do so little research
that you that you maybe accidentally do that within the first
24 hours of me being on the one work trip that I do consistently
every year, the one big thing, that's a one in 365 chance that
that was by accident, right? And it could be, but it's malicious
either way. It's malicious either way. >> Chance works.
What are the chances? Well, there are 365 days in a year, so
it's one out of 365.
>> No. Because you as a person creating this type of content
should ethically, responsibly understand. You should understand
a statistic anymore. >> Responsibility to be diligent,
right? To fact check to check primary sources and not just say
I'm sorry I there's a lot of physioamy clues here like his his
whole phenotype here. >> All right. His phenotype, his
archetype, his soul. There's so many things that point me towards
autism that I can't let him off the hook. Even if he's little
>> a little random present >> and be like, "Oh, this
person on whatever drama website." I don't even know if it was
TV farms or something else, honestly. At this point, >> he's
not even he's not even looking at the camera, bro. So, he can't
even make eye contact with the lens. Okay. You'll see the reflection
of his own eyes and it'll it'll break him. >> This person
said it. I'm going to repeat
>> Adam said this. It's probably untrue, right? Like
the content of the video is again not just here's the things
that I've said and I should be arrested by the thought police.
It's here's the things that he said. Here's him being afraid
degenerate and he should be shamed for this. Right? And here's
a bunch of other people who are not him that have said similar
things that have done abusive things. Therefore, and he says
in the video, you should connect the dots. There's usefulness
in connecting the dots, right? Cuz if you if you cancel someone
and ruin their lives for thoughts, then you're actually preventing
a real crime, right? Anyway, within my comments, I'm fighting
back a little in the sense that my thought process is, okay,
clearly this guy doesn't understand the importance of doing your
due diligence. He doesn't understand the importance of facteing.
He doesn't understand he's a commentary YouTuber. Of course,
he doesn't. He's got a bunch of people who will support him in
not doing any factecking and not being diligent, right? They
will literally support him in being at his >> Yeah, that
is the culture that commentary YouTube has.
Maybe uh maybe they need Turkey Tom to come back. I don't know.
They need something. They need something going on. Yeah. I don't
know if you want people to rest me at the for guy in his 40s
watching four movies a day and you're on the fence if he has
autism. To be fair, those four movies a day are for the inter
Toronto International Film Festival and he is a movie reviewer
by trade. So,
but you're >> I was just going to say you're saying maybe
they need Turkey Tom back, but didn't you have a lot of problems
with Turkey Tom's like some of his videos? He got a lot wrong
with the Max stuff. He got a lot left out with um his Destiny
>> I You know what? I don't know. I don't know if that's
really what they they need something. They need something. There's
going off the rails. >> They need a hero. I know one who
actually doesn't have a place to go right now. >> Who that?
Connor.
>> Okay.
He doesn't understand
why it would be important to not withhold proper context and
information, which he does throughout the video, right? Like
he show there's like one part where he shows a screenshot of
me interacting on Twitter with Shadman, right? A a screenshot.
I think there's like two of these ever has been my the extent
of my interactions with Shadman. By the way, a decade ago back
when not even going to name their names, but you know who I'm
talking about. the creators of everyone's favorite TV show right
now were on a podcast with him and hanging out with him and like
you know he was still doing lolly clearly >> wait what
wait everyone's favorite TV who is this Mr. Beast. No. What?
>> Oh, Keemstar. Keemstar. Right. >> Favorite. Wait.
Favorite television. >> A decade ago. Back when >> television
show. >> Not even going to name their names, but you know
who I'm talking about. The creators of everyone's favorite TV
show right now. We're on a everyone's favorite TV show right
now. I don't even >> Why do you think it was Keemstar?
>> I don't know. Psychic Pebbles. I don't even know who
the that is. This is going to be something where only like fries
and think it's like the best TV show, right? Smiling Friends.
Smiling Friends. This is going to be an animated show for kids,
but it's also going to be adults.
Of course it is. Of course it is. >> This is everyone's
favorite. >> It's a child's show, but for adults. Yes.
Obviously. Obviously.
Curious how this always seems to be the case. Very curious. >> This
is why I won't watch anime. >> Uh-huh.
Anime is just fun. Podcast with him and hanging out with him
and like, you know, he was still doing lolly. >> It's Adult
Swim. Okay. Clearly the you know the the the social
expectations around those conversations have shifted you know
like that was the that was the climate at the time where he was
a character that
drew weird including by the way adult human furry which I didn't
even jerk off to cuz I'm not a fan of his art style including
you know adult elastig girl or
>> Why does why does he do that? Why is it I didn't jerk
off to it cuz I don't like his art style. I don't know. In his
defense, if he did say the headline after that would be the response
would be like Nicholas Dioro quote tweeting that part with a
clip and be like YMS admits he jerks off to Shadman, right? >> a
tourniquet is on my line of thinking. It's like that's it's similar
to the that line just isn't hygienic.
>> Well, I didn't jerk off to that cuz you know what? His
brush strokes are too thick. Like what? >> Listen, the
line works sloppy, >> right? But he also did lolly You
know, I think that's mostly what he was known for. But there
were people in his social circle that were like, "Ah, whatever.
He's weird." You know, Shadman crossed the line. He crossed the
line by involving someone who is not a consenting adult. As soon
as he drew Keemstar's daughter, that was the situation where
he was no longer doing things that involved consensual adults.
He was involving people that were not
>> consentual adults. That's a clear line that was crossed.
I don't think I ever defended that ever. Involving people that
were not consentual adults. That's a clear line that was crossed.
Okay. I don't think I ever defended that ever. Right. Uh Ginger,
we are watching YMS. Your movie sucks. Adam defend his perpetual
decades long defense of
zoo files, uh engaging in healthy relationships, relationships
with their animals. And
well, that's probably the big one. He's just a lifelong furry
and sort of like a total degenerate, but like kind of publicly.
But >> I love I love him right here. He's like I don't
think I defended that ever. Right, guys? Right.
>> I don't think I Right. I didn't defend the Keemstar
daughter drawings. Right. Right. Right. >> I don't I don't
know. I don't think there's any interactions of me and him after
that point. And if there were, I probably didn't know about that.
Um I think there Yeah, I think there's literally two >> uh
it was Can the Jelly Man 2017 2018 somewhere in there. I think
there's literally two interactions and both of them were me not
responding just directly to him, but you can see like three other
people tagged in all of these cuz there was a big comment thread
and then I would make a joke. I made a joke like, "Hey, draw
my horse getting real by Scar." Whatever. Self-deprecating, you
know? >> That's the Darius, right? That's it's a >> How
is that self-deprecating? If you get to do the thing I want and
then if you don't, it's a joke.
>> Why do you just call it
>> I don't know. Yeah, I don't know.
>> That is okay. Now I feel it. You're right. You're right.
The >> humiliation thing the whole Yeah. >> Yeah.
Like part of the joke is like, "Hey, I'm a loser that wants to
bang scar from the lion king." In this guy's
>> he frames the fact that people in my community, you
guys, the people that are close, my core audience, the people
on my Patreon, he frames the fact and my subreddit, he frames
the fact that I have a core audience that accepts who I am as
a weirdo, a queer furry that wants to have scarf from the Lion
King. He frames that as me dodging accountability for a controversy.
He opens up the video saying that it's it's something that I've
successfully turned into a meme for my community. That it should
be a he says it's a controversy that I've turned into a meme.
Like I intentionally went uhoh. I don't want people to find out
that I actually want to have scarf in the Lang. Let's make it
a meme so I can muddy the waters and then no one knows if it's
true or not. No, dude. I'm just [__] open about myself.
I understand. >> Oh, hold on. >> Let's make a meme
so I can muddy the >> Did the pose? No way. >> Stop
it. He wants this. [__]
>> It's okay. I want this to I want to make fun of you,
too, buddy. This consenting adults doing We're both having a
great time. Okay, >> I consent. >> No, I'm just kidding.
Go ahead. Go >> No one knows if it's true or not. No, dude.
I'm just [__] open about myself. I understand the
absurdity of it. I grew up with that. Like, come on. Like, I
grew up in [__] Alberta. Do you know how like tough
it was to like
exist? You know, do you know how tough it was to like find out
this thing about myself that even though I knew is like harmless
and fantasy, right? I still hated myself into my early 30s. Like
I stopped hating myself at like age 31 for this. It sucked. It's
a long road. And that's why, you know, that's part of what informs
my decisions on how to treat other people and like why I don't
kink shame for consensual adult activities, right? As long as
you don't involve anyone that's not a consensual >> I don't
king shame for that [__] >> One of yours. One
of yours. I knew he was one of mine. I knew that. Okay. Listen,
this is this guy is not even one of the most embarrassing Albertan
Canadians making YouTube comment content right now. Okay,
>> uh someone do me a favor before he before Jay- Sock
even finishes this thought. Somebody find out did YMS did Adam
support the Black Elves or not? >> Oh, that's >> because
I feel like that that could get me to get Jay- Sock to flip on
him. >> Yeah. Oh, it could definitely. I'd have that argument
with him. >> Um, that's part of what informs that is like
I know how tough it is. I tried to repress it for two years of
my life. I tried to repress it. It wind up with me getting addicted
to crystal. Like, >> oh no. Oh, he's got the gene. I'm
sorry. He's got the gene. There's no
>> the LOL cow gene. >> Wait, what did he just say?
I just I must have missed it. He said, "I hated myself for 2
years trying to repress this stuff and it led to me getting addicted
to crystal crystal meth."
And I'm like, >> I'm like, "That is
almost certainly not related." Like, you like, "Oh, listen. I
could either be on and coke at the same time or I could let furry
dudes in furry suits rail me in the ass. It's one of the two."
>> This is what I was saying. You have to convince me.
Convince me why you need that horse in you. It's It's because
of substance abuse >> apparently. Yeah. >> Depression.
You will be depressed if you don't get horse. I It always comes
down to that.
>> I mean this is the first time I've heard it, but >> yeah,
I'll back it up so you can hear this again.
>> Early 30s. Like I stopped hating myself at like age
31 for this. It sucked. It's a long road. And that's why, you
know, that's part of what informs my decisions on how to treat
other people and like why I don't kink shame for consensual adult
activities, right? As long as you don't involve anyone that's
not a consensual, I don't shame for that. Um, that's part of
what is likeough.
I tried to repress it for two years of my life. I tried to wound
up with me getting addicted to Crystal. Like that was not fun,
but I'm a strong person.
>> Got super addicted, guys. >> I'm a strong person.
And that part's behind me, right? I I have I have >> overcoming
that is huge. So, I'm going to give him that.
>> Crystal addiction. >> Overcoming that. Yeah. >> Yeah.
Yeah, I just would have thought, you know,
go to like Narcotics Anonymous, go to like a treatment center.
I don't know how you ended up in like a furry convention to treat
that,
>> No, it's it's beforehand. So, >> do you think
he's like >> he said trying to repress it? He took drugs
and >> and stuff like that.
>> So, probably going to the furry convention is what led
him to the drugs. >> Maybe maybe he was maybe he's a successful
case of self-prescribing.
>> Cuz it seemed like when people talked about that furry
convention where they were in diapers and throwing them on people's
cars and in the stairwells.
>> And getting high and hot boxing their hotel rooms. I'm
thinking a lot of is going on there that might lead one to get
addicted to >> I actually think your your desire to be
a furry
just led you to be around drug
>> Yeah, it seems possible. >> Gone through a whole
lot of [__] in my life, right? Um, and now this guy
is like, "This is a controversy that he should have to answer
for being attracted to a Lion King character, right? And being
open about it." By the way, Nick in his stream repeatedly says
that I should be ashamed. That I should be ashamed for being
afraid repeatedly. I've archived it. >> Oh, he's not going
to fall back from that position at all. I think there are some
things that it's like it's one of those things where it's like
I don't know that I think the world's a better place for people
feeling like super comfortable sharing every single thing. And
I certainly know that you would get made fun of this if you just
shared it repeatedly all over the plate. Like I think you've
made bad decisions for your like well-being in this way. Is the
world better that we like all mock each other? Probably not.
>> But listen, but I understand I have empathy for this
as an ex oversharer
>> on the internet.
>> Yeah, I try not to overshare anymore. >> Mhm.
except for letting people know like when my period is or something
like that, but I feel like that's useful information for everybody
involved. Um
I feel like if I'm streaming,
we're involved in my cycle, but other than that, um I understand
like the desire to tell people stuff. Yeah.
But but no, it's not good. I forgot what what was the point that
I was making.
>> And so yeah, there's going to be some weird gaslighting.
There's going to be people coming out saying, "Oh, it has nothing
to do with you being a furry. Crazy. It has nothing to do with
any of the queer [__] you did. That's half the video.
That's half the video. If it has nothing to do with that, why
is that in
>> What is that face? >> Don't worry about it. >> Why
Why did you create propaganda by packaging all of this together?
Right. You look at the guy's channel.
It's Sam Height is awesome. At some point, okay, within I think
I believe within a year,
it'll depend on on how things shake out. We'll do eventually.
I'll have a camera on my face so you can see her reactions to
my face. We're gonna do like a >> No, they could just see
your face. They don't need to see my reaction to it. >> I
Yeah, sorry. I said a camera on my face and then you can see
what she's reacting to >> at some point. At some point.
Okay. And here's the Kiwi Farms of every liberal left-leaning
content creator. >> Like, he knows. Oh, hold on. Hold on.
>> Yeah, I don't freeleed. That sounds >> Right.
Uh, automatic week timeouts for anybody talking about period
stuff in chat for the rest of the night. >> That's not
fair. >> Rest of the night. >> That's not We're literally
talking. Look at what the conversation is. Talking about periods
and free bleeding is
kind of real lions, anthropomorphic lions, child anthropomorphic
lions. I don't give a I don't want to talk about period stuff
is gross. >> Look at the guy's channel.
>> It's Sam Height is awesome. And here's the Kiwi Farms
of every liberal left-leaning content creator. Like he knows
that's not wrong, right? Like that is actually what the Rob's
Media channel is. Like hold on, let's just go to Rob's Media
now. I don't I don't think he does
lift content creators. But the Gooner Files,
look, he's going after Nuaku right away. Okay, first video, Knoxaku.
Prolific right-wing grifting. Okay. Then we've got
>> then we've got YMS. Then we've got Denims. Then we've
got what?
>> Chris Tyson. >> Oh, latest. Okay. Yeah. >> Chris
Tyson. Sienna May. I have no idea who the Sienna May is.
Uh
Idubbbz. Mike from PA. And then those are all the idiot influencers
ones, right? Oh, no. Ethan is online. Big Doodle. Okay. So, he
does he does a couple videos. It's one of his series he does
is just basically taking >> kind of more left-leaning influencers.
He does a lot of the If Nick hates this guy, I hate this guy.
Nick hates this guy, I hate this guy. The continued degeneracy
of Denim's TV
stranger danger. Why I hate bread tubers. Vosch Xanderhal. Noah
Samson. That's Ana. Okay, it's like not super far off Denims.
Yeah,
he's not super far away from like the from what uh Ymss is describing.
I think this is like accurate enough. I don't think Yms is being
super misleading there. He knows that he has an audience full
of people that will react more uncharitably towards me if he
packages it with the queer furry, right? He knows that. That's
why he opened up the video talking about how I didn't love the
Prince of Egypt. That has nothing to do with any of any of the
[__] And then as you know, Nick's reading through
my com
is winning me back again.
>> Why?
Because like this guy is just
I think YMS should be shamed because like I think it's weird
and I think like some social normalization should be there. But
this guy probably thinks way way more conservative [__]
And this guy probably thinks, "Oh, YMS hates Christians. I'm
going to get him. I'm going to get him for this." >> Oh,
okay. >> Like the Prince of Egypt comment is actually totally
out of left field. It makes no sense. He's like this guy gave
Prince of Egypt like four out of 10 because he hates Christians.
come from? >> Yeah, it's like way out of left field. It
is actually [__] weird.
>> Yeah, that was that was like a ah that is one of those
things that it's like a big I wasn't thinking about it, but it
is like a big red flag like oh I'm going to say some really really
[__] now.
Yeah. Ah, I don't Nick is saying why is why is Adam talking about
all this that doesn't matter? Just get to the important stuff.
Dude, blame Rob for that. He he frontloaded the video with it,
right? Like I'm responding to everything. I get it. I have a
problem because I think that
especially in text form
this is dishonest.
My problem is thinking that to these people it's not going to
just show up as
wow you mad bro that's pretty long that's a lot of long text
right that's that's part of the reason why I think I'm is cuz
I seem to have like some kind of like obsession with you know
needing to feel like I I am able to convince people or correct
the record in some way of you know just being honest cuz I know
that I'm not an abuser I know that I'm not attracted to children
I know that I'm not attracted to animal I don't even jerk at
the lolly I hate that that's now a thing that people think uh
I know that about myself and so I feel like Oh, okay. Well, clearly
there's some sort of miscommunication. Clearly, there's a thing
where like someone doesn't understand me. And if I just say more
about myself, then it's fine cuz I know these things about myself,
so it's, you know, they'll figure it out. But that's not the
case. That's not the case. And after watching Nick's stream,
I'm kind of black on this [__] because even though,
you know, the commentary YouTube drama community, it's pretty
uh it's pretty homogeneous. I'm not saying that like
they all have the exact same opinions. Um, but I am saying that
they think very similarly. So, watching his stream was a bit
of a litmus test to understand how
assumed that he was aware he was severely off.
You >> assumed wrong.
>> This is why I kind of think I'm It's like, wait, what?
You only kind of think it like very likely the rest of the YouTube
drama commentary community is going to be talking about this.
Um Nick has made it very clear in his live stream that he's going
to be trying to get more people with larger audiences talking
about this. He says he wants to try and get H3 talking about
this because H3 has, you know, previously taken a very strong
stance against, you know, Loi or whatever. So, yeah, there's
going to be more coming. I
I like I could defend a lot of what this guy is saying if he
he's just like I don't I don't know.
Yeah, apparently Nick did say this. >> It just means that
the other dude is not he's not without criticism.
>> Yeah, I'm saying that like how do I put it? I think
Adam's previous arguments were bad and I think he is a little
bit correct that it seems like he's a little better at making
them now. Like he's a little better at like I think if he wasn't
quite so
What? How do you say that after he just said so much stupid [__]
in this video? >> Oh, you're right. Well, he's saying stupid,
but it's different.
>> This is like more understandable stupid.
>> Like, it's a little more It's a little more understandable.
>> What are you talking We're like We're 1 hour into so
much.
>> Yeah. He makes really weird comments.
and mind you, I'm not saying that means, oh, you should be locked
up. It's like I understand why people wouldn't make fun of you.
>> I understand why people are yucking your
>> Yeah, but I'm saying even beyond that, right? Uh, hold
on. Hold on. We've got we've got enough time to finish this.
Trust me, we've got enough time to finish this. Um, what am I
trying to think of? Oh, how do I describe it? I think that he
would probably think that it's not necessar this probably we're
arguing not over the thing he was arguing. We're arguing over
he doesn't want to be socially shamed. He thinks it's been really
hurtful for him to be socially shamed for these things and that
he had a lot of self-hatred and it was difficult for him to get
over. That's the actual argument he has. But he he sits on like
the legality thing. We wouldn't even argue like, "Oh, you should
be locked up for some drawing you've done, right?" >> Like
we're not arguing that. So the real argument that we would have,
the real contention we would have with him is how badly should
you be socially shamed and should there be empathy extended for
if it's like really dragging you down in life? Should we have
empathy for him there? And then how much do we disagree on that?
Like >> I think for me it's very similar to the
people where if it's such a struggle for you that you need to
let me know that you're a there's something weird happening here.
>> Like if you could just keep it to yourself, it wouldn't
be that big a deal. like you're actually not a when and all you
think about is how much you want to let people know that you're
a
>> so how much of that do you think is or how much of that
could you forgive if he looks at it from the perspective if he
was to tell you okay let's say his argument here or what what
he would say here is I
am not you know I don't even think it's good for society society
to be this way but I think it's important for people to be like
aware of these beliefs of my beliefs and so that people like
me who would suffer in the way that I feel like I suffered would
be aware that like there's a possibility to like get through
it. >> Yeah. So then it just seems like you're doing an
advertisement. You're like you're like putting out a bat signal
>> for other confused pretty broken who were pretty close
to being addicted to drugs like you. >> Yeah. Yeah. >> And
then I think
you not be the spokeserson
or can you not try to attract very vulnerable people to yourself
cuz I think what you just got through addiction. You're probably
not
supposed to be like the sponsor for other people. >> I
think this is like 8 n years ago. He's like 40 now. So it was
like >> Okay. But he's losing his mind. Like he's losing
his because someone made a YouTube video about him while he was
out at a convention. Okay. You're not the arbiter of I've got
everything locked down and I should help guide other people who
are like navigating their way through these rough waters.
>> Maybe you >> I'm trying to tell you like if he
hypothetically was like even from a naive place was saying, "Well,
I think I can actually I think like people like me feel ashamed
and feel like there's no hope." And if I could get people through
that feeling of no hope or that lack of hope, then I feel like
that would be okay. I can take the punishment. I could take like
the people calling me whatever names if I get like a couple people
through this lack of hope. >> I need to be convinced that
that is something that exists in the world and that's something
that's useful because I think there are a lot of lost people.
I think there are a lot of people who want to feel unique, who
want to feel like they have a label for what's wrong with them
and
usually whoever offers them a solution, that's the first place
that they're going to identify with. So there are people who
aren't even furries, but they're going through stuff that they
might start identifying with being a furry because they feel
like they found somebody who will take care of them and cuddle
them. >> Yeah. I think that's happened with trans people
way more. Like trans people would be the way bigger example of
that where I think that that's happened where people aren't trans,
but they're like going through and they find a community that's
like ultra accepting of them and they'll go to that community
and be convinced like you might actually be and they'll like
go through that stuff and realize like no, I'm not. But they
just were like vulnerable. They're in a vulnerable place, right?
>> I think that could be furry communities. >> Uh,
probably. Yeah. >> The laring communities, all of those.
>> I should say also that I'm I'm making like arguments
for him. It's like my overactive empathy. Like I don't think
he's actually made this precise argument himself. I'm saying
if that were what he was saying, I feel like I could understand
that, but I know that's overactive empathy in my head. So, I
would need him to actually say those words for me to be like,
"Okay, I can kind of understand where you're coming from." I
don't think he's like made this argument specifically. I'm just
like kind of thinking of like, okay, it seems like he's going
in that direction. Like I think he's made some arguments kind
of like that. He's like said things kind of like that. Like how
he >> That's like a red flag for me. >> Uh what's
a red flag? >> When I see somebody wants to be like a role
model. >> Oh, I see. When I see somebody who goes through
really hard moments in life and feels like because I went through
hard moments, I want to guide other people going through hard
moments,
that is like a that's a big red flag to me. Like when someone
makes a whole online movement and their concern is like disaffected
>> Yeah. Yeah.
>> Like why are you so interested in >> What's that?
It's something like Oh, it's the woof sound effect. Yeah. And
and it's not to say that that's not a valid
>> thing that there are a lot of people who are concerned
for that do dedicate their lives to help and support, but I'm
not going to I'm not going to buy that from every with a tiny
violin on YouTube. >> Yeah, that's it. >> That's
totally fair. Uh sleep dealer, thank you for the primer over
on Twitch. Really appreciate it, buddy. Thank you. Thank you.
Uh, for sure you can guarantee that like
especially especially because I fought back at it all by
you know when I'm when I'm saying in all caps like dude you're
showing with minors is that the most charitable most contextual
contextual version of what they did. No, that's my point right
that's my point is because in a reality where someone has any
bit of introspection they would look at that and go oh wait it's
bad to withhold information. Wait, it's bad to present things
in a way that's clearly framed in propaganda. Even if these things
are technically true, the things I said are technically true,
right? He did show the minors, right? He directed minor super.
However, in my comments, right, unlike Rob's video, in my comments,
in the exact same thread, I give the most charitable interpretation.
I go, "Here's exactly what you did." And it's not a quippy sound.
It's not a meme. Right?
So, anybody who's like, "Oh, wait. They showed the miners." In
the same thread goes, okay, that's what he meant. Even on Twitter,
even on Twitter, it's like within the same thread, right? There's
nothing that I've said that like even even if it is like the
less charitable way to phrase it, which is the point. It's not
untrue, but it's the less charitable way to phrase it. That's
the point. What I've said, anybody can go, "Oh, what do they
mean?" And it's right there. With Rob's video, it's not Rob's
video only contains uncharitable
with no context, no information. He doesn't give the context
of like, you know, the shad man, right? Obviously, um, in Rob's
video, you know, he he showcases all the times
that I've defended myself on Reddit.
I'm surprised that like a lot of some commentary YouTubers haven't
realize that like there is a way to make a commentary video.
I think Ethan Klein tries to do this, but he like fails because
he's like cataclysmically repeated sometimes. But if you like
anticipate what their defenses will be and try to show like enough
context so that they don't they can't really make the argument
you haven't shown it like like I think his argument here is with
the shadman thing. Oh there are a bunch of people requesting
things and I was like making a joke. It's like you could say
oh like when you're doing it you could write it in a way where
it's like he'll say something like this
but that here's why it's like when you do the preemptive like
here's the most common but they a lot of slot tubers just don't
do that and it's like not even hard to do. >> I don't know.
I feel like they would benefit so much from doing stuff like
that. Uh Ryan Beard did that incredibly well in his content video,
right? Where he's like, "Here's like the here's the here's the
argument I think they're gonna make. Here's why that's >> I
think and and Adam's like if you were trying to nail Adam if
you thought Adam was really harmful, which I don't think there's
an argument he's like tremendously harmful." You could say, "Oh,
well, he collects like some weird people." But I think probably
I don't believe that based on most of the people who watch him
like a lot of people who are aware of him like very very heavily
aware of him don't even know that he's like into this or like
they might know he's a furry but they don't even know that he
like has the not safe for work >> I feel like people have
told me in the past that he's a furry and I just I didn't even
remember it until I saw this stuff come up. >> Yeah. Yeah.
Yeah. So like I I think there's not really good argument, but
if you were trying to nail them, I think you can actually do
that and it can work pretty well how w with like that can work
pretty well to it can go towards like convincing people of your
side and then it's harder for them to respond, >> but this
guy didn't do that at all. I think you could have cut cut off
this response and you wouldn't have had anything to say about
the the shad man >> because people will, you know, bring
this up on Reddit and demand that I respond to it and so I'll
respond to it because I have a problem thinking that, you know,
me in my own brain knowing that I haven't done anything wrong.
I have a problem by thinking that I can explain that to people
with words. Apparently, that's not possible for a good amount
of the population. I need to figure this out at some point. Right?
The reason why this is going to blow up more is because in me
defending myself, I can see how Nick reacted to this. And so
I have a good idea of how the general commentary community is
going to react to this. And Nick basically saw my defense, me
being like, "Hey, you shared with miners in all caps." Clearly
making a point, right? He saw that as me being malicious and
doesn't see the original video as being malicious. So he thinks
that he thinks that the start of malice was my response. And
so that's unfortunately like I don't know, maybe, you know, maybe
Tom's going to grant me the benefit of the doubt. Maybe other
people are. Maybe Nick's the outlier here, but it seems like
that's what they're going to go with. They're going to say that
Rob's video not propaganda, not misleading, not malicious, not
strategically edited, not leaving out information or just ignore
it and not even acknowledge it or just
uh I think if you're going to make the argument about how he's
leaving out information. I don't think that Adam's actually done
a good job of showing what information is left out in some of
these things. He says things are left out. He's doing the Hassan,
right? >> He's going there's context missing. There's a
bunch of context missing. And I'm like, "Okay, could you like
maybe there are Reddit comments, like additional Reddit comments?
Have you gone and looked at everything?" And it's like, "Adam
hasn't shown any of that. What's the additional context? What's
he hasn't even talked about what context is
>> He gave me context on other reasons why he hasn't
or he's not attracted to real
>> Gave me a bunch of context I didn't >> Are we
Are we team dog here? What's What's happening?
>> No, I don't think so. But I maybe want to extend like
a little uh what do you call it? Like empathy to Adam where I
don't think he's ne not I don't think he's like necessarily harmful
enough that he needs like a video. And he's he's thrown a couple
little arguments that actually kind of get me slightly back.
At least
he's like doing a good job of convincing me that slop tubers
like a lot of commentary YouTubers who don't do any research
like suck enough that I don't care about their videos. What do
you think? >> What's he actually I don't really watch the
Rob video. I'm going to be honest. I wish like 5 minutes of it
and then skipped around.
>> Um, what's the worst thing that happened? What's the
worst thing he's >> The worst thing he's done?
>> it's a lot of like he's just a he's like a total apparently
apparently. >> We've actually we've actually confirmed
that he does have like a account where he does his own like free
amateur where he's getting by like black dudes and furry costumes
and [__]
>> Okay. And >> so I do think I think he's weird.
I think it warrants bullying
and
that there's nothing wrong with that. >> Yeah, bullying
basically like social correction. Nothing should be illegal.
I think the part where he gets into trouble is he goes with the
the uh you shouldn't be in trouble for any drawn image, right?
He's like the he's doing the lolly defense and Nicholas didn't
like that. Okay. Nicholas didn't like his lolly defense. Rob
didn't like his >> We haven't I don't think we've seen
that part yet. Uh some of the arguments he does for vegan Oh,
he also basically does he does the Vosch argument, but he does
it with animals. You you know the Vosch argument where he says
um >> yeah, but the animal >> possible for an old
man. >> Where does your moral outrage come from? Where
does your moral outrage come from? >> No, no, no, no, no,
no, no, no. I'm I don't have any I I understand that that could
be a thing. I'm saying he does another argument which is the
Vosch argument of it's not it's not the child and then uh capitalism.
It's the there could be theoretically a healthy relationship
between an adult and a child that's and it benefit both of them.
He does that argument basically but for animals like you have
an animal that has a diminished capacity to consent and theoretically
you could have
>> dog really wants to your dog really want and you just
let it die. >> That's like the that's the argument. >> That's
the argument. Yeah. Yeah. >> And it's like probably there
are good arguments for why you shouldn't even be making that
argument, right? like all of the rule util versus utilitarian
arguments or I forget there's like a what's what's the non-rule
utilitarian there's like a
>> yeah I don't know I I'm trying to think of like how
people describe this but he >> as weird
>> yeah it's all weird act utilitarian right right act
utilitar yeah so he's like doing the the act util argument and
it's like yeah probably not a good
>> yeah at the end of the day it's just like making arguments
like you know it's about like animals. Like I said, it's like
it's not like it's all about you know kids. I understand if you're
like really freaked out by someone making arguments about [__]
kids. Someone making arguments about animals like you eat animals
off your high horse. This isn't that bad really, is it? There's
way worse happen. >> No, no, no. There's a there's like
an evolved there's an evolved suppression for your disgust response
in eating animals, right? That kept you alive for so long. >> It
was so he was making some of those like vegan arguments, but
he's also not a vegan. Yeah, he's not even a like I thought I
thought he was like, "Oh, I love animals and you guys don't even
like animals and then we found a video of him eating steak with
like So, we thought he was vegan. It's like, okay, he's like
making the, "Oh, I don't want to harm animals. I'm actually less
harmful to animals than you." And no, he's just he like actually
just I don't >> He just he does this thing. He
He says, "There's nothing wrong with
this dog or there's nothing wrong with a horse because you do
worse." It's like this hypocrisy point. like you're a hypocrite
for having a problem with this, >> which both of them are
bad and neither of them are bad. I think that's the point, right?
>> Um, no. I think I think the argument is society has
this like suppression of disgust response because we ate animals
to like survive at one point and you think that we should have
to match that evolved response with like our response to and
it's like no, I can just have the revulsion decision and admit
that we should probably do better on the eating animals front
and the animal cruelty >> Well, okay. You're just saying
you're just like coming up with like an intellectualized way
to say really icky but you actually just agree with literally
what I just said. >> He overintellectualized
too much of >> Both of them are bad or >> you say
it's intellectualized but it what what do you disagree with?
>> Well, that's what I'm saying. You just said that as
if you were disagreeing with me, but you actually just said exactly
what I'm saying. Either either both of them are bad or neither
of them are. That's just >> No, I said I said actually
I said actually I'm totally fine with keeping one. I'm totally
fine with being inconsistent. I can say they're both bad, but
I'm totally fine with being inconsistent. I think the idea where
he goes because his next argument is and I just want consistency
here. I think wanting consistency
with being No, no, because you're saying you're fine with being
inconsistent, but you're not cuz you're saying we try and do
better on the eating animals front. So, you're obviously not
fine with being consistent. You think we should be
>> Uh, we should be, but I'm fine with doing like moving
no direction there. And I'm fine with saying I don't want to
be I I know that it'll be tough to solve the what do you call
>> Okay. And that that's that's like a
>> So people say like if you live in a society and you
don't have criticisms, if you're not going to be a vegan that
you can't really criticize people for animals. And I just think
that's stupid. >> Well, you can't morally criticize. >> Okay.
I don't make a I don't really make a difference between a moral
criticism and me making fun of you for something that's like
totally disgusting. Like in terms of >> there is two different
weird for you to do that. I feel like I understand that there
is a intellectualized difference, but in terms of like I don't
know anything else like having a practical discussion with somebody
just >> but that's the root of it because every time I
keep >> it just sounds like you're coming up with a million
different ways to just you're just coming up with a million different
ways to avoid saying >> basically that there's a that you
know one of them's they're both a girl and either male. They
just that that is >> okay. But hold on saying that. >> The
only thing that Adam does is say everybody is moral grandstanding.
You're being right. He he >> the idea that he's getting
bullied. The people bullying him are just implying that they
are like morally better than he is. >> Rob's media is moral
grandstanding in that video. >> Rob's media. But I'm saying
everybody else like the cuz he's he's getting >> Yeah.
There's a lot of people that would just say that would just say
Yeah. Yeah. A lot of people just say that's [__]
gross. >> But lots of people moral grandanding on >> No.
No. Of course. But but most people don't say that. Most people
go, "Oh my god, it's so wrong and and evil that someone would
think it's okay to [__] animal. It's like you eat
animals. What do you mean it's so wrong and evil?" That's what
most people say. Most people say, "Oh my god, it's abuse. It's
evil." You you eat animals.
Do you think there's not like a social degeneracy argument that
you're cutting against like the social >> you can make
arguments about how about how it's antisocial and how it it's
like not behavior you should engage in because it can offput
your family and cause issues or some like this. You can make
many of those same arguments like Adam would say for being for
being gay in a time where it was not acceptable to be gay too.
But regardless, you can make those arguments and uh you know
you can be homophobic and justify it. >> Yeah. You just
want to you just want to come here and have the argument versus
like the the weakest version of it. You're going to say everybody
just thinks, "Oh, you're so no." Okay.
>> Evil dogs. >> Shouldn't there be some ratio of
utility to like social deviency that needs to be like respected
like basically or people are just engaging like the >> weird?
Okay. So, is it okay to be gay when people are against gay people?
I just I say probably it's actually arguably like not necessarily
depending on how bigoted the society is, right? To to start advocating
for this, right? Like you're you're probably causing like some
amount of social harm to people who get stoned, right? >> So
I mean you have that perspective, but it's not most people's
perspective. You know, most people think we actually should have
social progress and so they're not going to like them that >> that
a system should there should be a ratio, right? like is in your
>> if everyone adopts if everyone if everyone system there's
no movement. >> What if a thousand years from now it's
actually okay to like eat your young and that's totally but like
right now I don't think you should advocate just because at some
future point we've progressed to the point where we actually
we understand that like oh you know before a certain age you're
below a certain cognitive threshold and >> is that harmful
now? Is that harmful now? Holy sh. But I I feel like the the
whole thing with being gay at a time where it wasn't accepted
is you actually you accepted and you acknowledged why certain
people stayed in the closet out of fear, right? Because they
were going against the social norm. And you also acknowledged
the heroism or I think that's a word that you would use for people
who spoke out and were proudly gay and would explain why it was
fine to be gay. They didn't do
This is a very kind of lame conversation cuz I feel like you
guys have just tried to come up with, oh, here's how I justify
being disgusted by this. It's
justifying I am disgusted.
I am disgusted by it. >> You're just going to say that
over and over again as if it's making a good point. You're mad
that I just don't think you're
not arguing anything cuz you you've got
an argument
characterized my argument like three >> You're just like
pisco
>> I can't get out. I literally I can barely speak. I can't
even get through a full sentence before you get what I'm >> Well,
because because JC is helping you, okay, by cutting me off the
person who's making the >> Go ahead. Go ahead. >> Yeah.
If if you stop chiming in after I make a good point, then he
can respond. >> Okay. Go ahead. I'm waiting for Quman to
respond. That's a lot of time. >> Well, I don't know. I
don't know what point you I didn't know what I was responding
to. I thought you were going to go. I thought >> Okay.
You're making the argument that like, oh, the the response to
him is that it's evil that you're dogs or it's evil that you
want to [__] dogs. >> Uh, no, I'm not saying
that. I think it's gross. >> No, that's >> Well,
I'm not a lot of people, so you have to actually engage with
what I'm saying, right? >> Okay. Well, I don't have anything
to engage with there. I just I agree. Yeah, it's gross to dogs
and it's kind of weird to bring up how you how it should be okay
to dogs. I agree with that. There's no arguing that there. >> Oh,
okay. So, you don't even agree with Adam. What the [__]
are you doing?
>> What? No, I I'm saying about Rob's media's video.
That was moral grandstanding from what I saw. And most of the
response Adam gets is moral grandstanding. So, of course, when
he's going to respond when he's responding to criticism, that
is how he's responding to that. He's he's arguing it. He's saying,
"Well, how are you going to get on the moral high horse about
this when you eat meat when you support, you know, like cows
getting for milk, you know?" >> And I I've already said
it's it's >> Yeah, you could talk to now cuz he's clearly
just pretending to be >> it's his argument. It's his uh
like uh what do you call it? Act utilitarian argument around
animals,
right? Which is probably the the assailable thing that
>> Yeah. Well, I mean, >> I already said I didn't
I I already said I didn't even disagree. >> Then you're
saying then you're saying, "Oh, we can't have certain conversations."
I feel like most people wouldn't agree with that either. I feel
like if someone actually argued that most people would >> You
can have a conversation, but you have to deal with you have to
deal with how everybody else like handles it and obviously
and posted a bunch of YouTube threads and absolutely luck out
over over this thing. >> Well, yeah, sure. But that's not
really uh
responding to any point he's making. That's saying, "Wow, you're
really embarrassing yourself, bro.
I I responded to the act utilitarian point he made. >> Yeah,
but No, no, no. You're saying you probably shouldn't have these
types of conversations. I thought you were saying that was like
a real utilitarian thing you were saying is that you shouldn't
even have these types of conversations because of the negative
outcome. >> I'm saying that it's pretty just it's pretty
like uh you can have the conversation, but he believes that,
right? And he gives like a fullon fullthroated defense for why
he believes it. He says, "I'm attracted to Scar and I would never
a real lion, so obviously I can understand like why somebody
could blah blah blah blah blah blah blah." And then he's like,
"Oh, and also >> there's there's a couple other things
that go along." Sorry, I actually just gave the wrong point.
But he's um he basically gives like his point. He's like, I understand
how you could be attracted to only certain features, but I also
understand like
he gives the the like uh what do you call it that I think his
argument is dolphins try to rape people and obviously there's
some agency and consent on the part of the dolphin >> Yeah.
Wait, I I heard I heard through Chudstream I heard in his response
him talking about animal consent. I mean there is obviously some
kind of like form of consent in the animal kingdom that's not
human consent. Is that do you not agree with that? Animals can
consent to each other. Do you think you should meet that same
bar? Do you think you can actually meaningfully have like match
>> No, I thought he he said that you can't. I thought he
said that he doesn't think humans can have consensual relationships
with animals in this in this response
>> in he he says they can't have informed consent, but
you can have the same consent an animal would have with another
animal. That's what he says. >> Yeah, that's >> he
says you can't have informed consent. Yeah. I don't think >> that's
what you were saying with um >> the Voch argument where
well there's a percentage chance >> the actual argument.
Yeah. >> So okay dolphin
a woman or what what is okay dolphin a woman versus woman like
what's the what's the difference here with the dolphin's consent?
>> There is no difference with the dolphin's consent. >> But
if you if you >> is one wrong increased capacity to entice
the dolphin to you. Right. There's something going on there that
I mean it's a non-consensual it's a non-consensual fact if the
dolphin pins you down and rapes you in the water. Right. Like
you don't have >> Yeah. Yeah. But let's say let's say like
you know
the dolphin like looks like it's coming over and the woman's
like I wouldn't mind getting by dolphin and just kind of let
to happen. What what is the what is the moral uh is that wrong?
>> Uh is it morally wrong if the woman Yeah. If the woman
assumes that if the woman thinks the dolphin's coming over to
I think so. I think that's probably wrong. I don't think she's
>> because of the state of mind
>> or because of the inaction. >> Yeah, there's like
a there's like an example somebody gave of like if you go to
the army and you say, "I want to sign up cuz I just want to kill
a bunch of brown people." They probably go, "Yeah, actually we
don't want you." But realistically, their their mission is to
go and kill a bunch of brown people.
>> Yeah. But we wouldn't say something to your state of
mind there where it's like, "Oh, >> if you join the army,
if you if you join the army because you want to keep a bunch
of brown people,
you're probably a person. But just in that you haven't done something
wrong >> And the woman who's baiting the dolphin is a >> wait
what I is a >> person
not
saying she's
so >> what we're talking about. But what I'm saying is
I'm distinguishing being a [__] person. You haven't
done anything wrong yet as a as as the the racist person joining
the army. Just like you know I I don't like at what point does
the wrong action occur with the woman who allows
>> killing people? Um, I would say as you form the like
intent to not evade the dolphin, as you like get into the water
knowing it could have like there's there's something building
there, right? >> It's it's the it's and the other thing
about the human animal relationships is you can't really trust
these people to like have the animals best interest at heart
when they're trying to get something else out, right >> of
that relationship. So, they're an increased capacity at an increased
like capacity to consent, right? It's just like you wouldn't
I don't know >> like they're looking for signals that aren't
there. >> Not letting a babysit your like daughter or something,
right? For this exact reason. Like they might not actually be
hateful, but it's like there is just some some amount of
>> I would not like read a dog 100%. I'm with I'm with
you on that part. But I just don't know in like if you're using
utilitarianism, I don't know how you disting what
where is the wrong act between why why is being by a dolphin
you're doing >> the inability to pick the I suppose
of it not being a problem,
>> Well, I'm well I'm not saying you know this isn't like
>> Yeah, I don't know where the line is.
I think there's probably like uh like you'd have to delineate,
right, some some decision where they they know that this might
happen with the dolphin and they have the ability to like pull
away, right? So they're not getting >> How how much effort
do you have to put >> in trying to get away from the dolphin
before you're doing something wrong?
>> Can you go back to the avatar that's just you? Yeah,
sure.